du jour appelle la discussion en
nouvelle lecture de la proposition de
loi maintenant provisoirement un
dispositif de plafonnement de
revalorisation de la variation annuelle
des indices locatifs la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué
chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du tourisme
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
le président de la commission des
affaires économiques monsieur le
rapporteur Cazenave mesdames messieurs
les députés nous voici de retour
pour la nouvelle lecture de cette
proposition de loi visant à maintenir
provisoirement un dispositif de
plafonnement de revalorisation
des indices locatifs c'est je l'espère
je n'en doute pas autant un plaisir pour
vous que pour moi
je tenterai une pointe d'humour en
relevant que certains parmi vous
regrettez un examen trop rapide et
qu'ils doivent donc être aujourd'hui
encore plus réjouis
pour ma part les constats que je
dressais devant vous lors de la première
lecture et c'est plutôt rassurant non
pas changé
l'inflation certes ralentit s'établit au
mois de mai vous le savez mesdames
messieurs les députés à 5,1% sur un an
cette projection et le commencement
d'une bonne nouvelle même s'il est
encore bien sûr trop tôt pour
s'enthousiasmer il est trop tôt pour
s'enthousiasmer mais au moins nous
basons nous sur les projections les plus
fiables à date à notre disposition c'est
bien pourquoi nous avons dû attendre
avant de nous rallier à cette
proposition de prolongation du
plafonnement des loyers commerciaux dès
lors
si le Sénat a voulu rejeter ce texte en
bloc Argan qui de la méthode qui du
calendrier je me permets d'en appeler à
votre responsabilité par trois fois et
je l'espère sincèrement bientôt 4 vous
avez voté en faveur de cette proposition
de loi en conscience j'en suis certaine
vous avez voté en faveur du dispositif
proposé par votre rapporteur qui prévoit
de prolonger ni plus ni moins
jusqu'au premier trimestre 2024 le
plafonnement à 3,5% de l'évolution de
l'indice des loyers commerciaux pour les
PME nous aurons au cours des prochaines
heures l'occasion de débattre à nouveau
des aménagements que certains proposent
à ce dispositif
soyez assuré que mon avis n'a pas varié
depuis le 31 mai dernier le gouvernement
est très favorable au dispositif proposé
par le rapporteur ont ce qu'il est
équilibré mesurer dans sa durée dans son
intensité des bacs nous avions déjà vu
dans pas déjà eu déjà eu mais aussi dans
son périmètre cette proposition de loi
elle prend garde à préserver des
équilibres qui sont très importants si
on souhaite que ce plafonnement soit
rapidement validé d'abord en ciblant les
commerçants qui sont les plus exposés
les plus petits nos TPE nos PME c'est à
dire les entreprises qui ont les marges
les plus faibles et bien souvent le
moins de latitude dans leur négociation
avec les bailleurs en particulier les
foncières
ensuite en bornant cette intervention
dans le temps jusqu'au premier trimestre
2024 date à laquelle l'inflation pour
soutenu quel demeure devrait devrait
être avoir nettement refluer enfin en
conservant le taux de 3,5% qui fait
l'objet d'un consensus entre toutes les
parties prenantes si tentait que les
deux premiers critères soient respectés
sur ces trois critères
de durée d'intensité et de périmètre
nous agissons avec prudence parce qu'en
matière d'intervention de l'État sur les
relations contractuelles vous le savez
mesdames messieurs les députés la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est toujours montrer et à juste titre
pointilleuse dans un état de droit
l'État est fort heureusement n'a pas
tous les droits
constante dans ma position au nom du
gouvernement je suis aussi constante
dans les propositions
au-delà de l'urgence de la situation je
vous renouvelle donc mon offre de
poursuivre le travail structurel sur le
bail commercial de façon plus large dans
le cadre du Conseil national du commerce
comme vous j'observe les mutations
structurelles de ce secteur comme vous
je souhaite y apporter des réponses de
long terme les attentes sont
légitimement nombreuses en la matière
sur le calcul de l'IMC d'une part et
plus largement sur le bail commercial je
ne serais donc pas plus longue de façon
invariable le gouvernement soutient
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
en soutient un défectible de nos petits
commerçants et avec eux des
consommateurs ils ont encore besoin que
nous les accompagnons pour les mois qui
viennent en plafonnant c'est indice des
loyers commerciaux je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre délégué
chargé de la ville et du logement
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers Olivia monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés votre assemblée
doit aujourd'hui examiner deux nouveaux
la proposition de loi du député Thomas
Cazenave et de ses collègues afin de
prolonger le bouclier loyer qui a été
mis en place grâce à la loi de
protection du pouvoir d'achat dites muta
en juillet dernier
en effet en juillet 2022 le Gouvernement
a souhaité protéger les Français des
conséquences inédites de l'inflation
un an après alors que l'inflation est
encore présente cet objectif doit
perdurer c'est notre devoir comme il y a
un an je me félicite qu'une majorité des
députés est votée en faveur de ce
dispositif de protection de pouvoir
d'achat depuis plusieurs semaines vous
avez eu l'occasion par trois fois de
débattre de dispositifs
utile et bénéfiques par trois fois une
majorité d'entre vous a voté en faveur
de ce texte par trois fois vous avez
voté en faveur d'un dispositif qui a été
en mesure de limiter l'impact de la
forte inflation sur les hausses de loyer
et de rendre prévisible à un taux
maîtriser les dépenses de logement et
les aides au logement je le redis avec
force cette mesure a démontré son
efficacité pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat sans ce plafonnement l'IRL
aurait dépassé 6 % au deuxième trimestre
2023 et les loyers du parc social et du
parc privé aurait dû augmenter à ce
niveau
or les prévisions d'inflation font état
d'une poursuite pendant encore quelques
trimestres de la dynamique
inflationniste concrètement cela
signifie que si nous ne prolongeons pas
de quelques mois la protection des
locataires grâce au plafonnement de
l'IRL il pourra y avoir des hausses de
loyer de plus de 6 % dans le parc privé
d'ici la fin de l'année 2023 et de plus
de 4% en début de l'année 2024 certains
d'entre vous notamment à la gauche de
cette hémistique souhaite s'opposer à
cette mesure en se posant à cette mesure
équilibrée et proportionnée qui répartit
l'effort entre locataire et propriétaire
vous risquez d'aggraver la crise et de
faire courir un risque au locataire
modeste
il faudra leur dire qu'en faisant fi
d'un esprit d'équilibre et de compromis
vous permettez ainsi au loyer
d'augmenter fortement
comme selon vous la mesure ne va pas
assez loin vous préférez voter contre ce
n'est pas notre vision des choses ce
gouvernement cette majorité de nombreux
députés font le choix de la
responsabilité et de l'équilibre entre 0
et 6,5 % nous vous proposons un
compromis par cette mesure nous faisons
gagner à tous les locataires du parc
privé en moyenne 15 euros par mois dans
le contexte actuel ce n'est pas rien les
prochains mois vont encore être
difficiles c'est un fait l'inflation va
refluer comme annoncer mais un peu plus
tard que prévu initialement par rapport
à nos prévisions alors qu'il y a un
risque que les locataires rencontrent
des difficultés dans cette période nous
ne pouvons pas les laisser sans solution
après le 30 juin alors que l'inflation
est toujours là il nous faut les aider
les aider c'est prolonger le bouclier
loyer jusqu'au moins le premier
trimestre 2024 c'est le moment où l'IRL
devrait retrouver son niveau de 2022
c'est à dire moins de 3, 5%. les aider
c'est tenir l'engagement qui avait été
pris en juin 2022 au moment de la loi
pour la protection du pouvoir d'achat
cet engagement c'était celui de protéger
les locataires du pic d'inflation
aujourd'hui nous finissons le travail
commencé en juin 2022 nous tenons nos
engagements jusqu'au bout en prolongeant
le dispositif nous arriverons ainsi à la
fin du pic d'inflation prévu pour début
2024 en prolongeant le dispositif nous
protégerons ainsi les Français sur toute
la durée de la période d'inflation cette
valeur de 3 et demi pour cent c'est le
respect de notre constitution du droit
de propriété qui permet d'investir de
produire d'accroître le nombre de
logements si nous devons protéger les
locataires nous ne devons pas fragiliser
les propriétaires dont une partie sont
des propriétaires modestes malgré ce que
certains voudraient toujours nous faire
croire
j'appelle bien sûr les propriétaires qui
le peuvent à poursuivre l'effort de
solidarité nationale et donc à ne pas
augmenter les loyers s'ils le peuvent
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
bouclier loyer est un levier pour
permettre que le logement reste
abordable mais d'autres actions se
menées pour faire en sorte que le
logement ne mette pas en péril la
promesse républicaine
je le dis car tant ici qu'au Sénat et je
regrette d'ailleurs que le texte n'est
pas été adopté par la Chambre haute j'ai
entendu des considérations qui ne
dépendent pas de ce texte ce texte vient
prolonger une mesure temporaire
juridiquement et temporellement ciblé
au même problème nous appliquons la même
solution ce texte n'a pas vocation et sa
n’a jamais été le cas ni son objectif de
répondre à la crise que nous connaissons
du logement pour répondre à la crise du
logement le gouvernement est à la tâche
des premières propositions étaient
faites la feuille de route est claire ce
qui compte et c'est pour ça que je suis
engagé en politique c'est d'améliorer la
vie des français par exemple nous avons
signé vendredi dernier la convention
quinquennale avec Action Logement avec
la première ministre Christophe Béchu et
les partenaires sociaux pas plus tard
que ce matin nous avons lancé j'ai lancé
le plan logement d'abord 2 suite aux
annonces de la première ministre à la
restitution du Conseil national de la
refondation logement ce plan logement
d'abord c'est 440 000 personnes qui ont
quitté la rue pour un logement pérenne
ce plan logement d'abord c'est 160
millions d'ici la fin du quinquennat et
500 millions d'euros sur cinq ans c'est
la création de 10000 places nouvelle de
pension de famille de 30000 places en
intermédiation locative d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat je pense aussi au
renforcement du bail réel solidaire ou
bien encore à la rénovation du parc
social d'autres propositions viendront
je sais
je le sais que vous serez sur les bancs
mobilisés sur ce sujet important du
logement nous travaillerons ensemble
pour relever le défi et permettre de
mieux loger de loger tous nos
concitoyens mesdames et messieurs les
députés ce texte sur lequel vous avez à
vous prononcer
et donc un texte au service du pouvoir
d'achat des locataires des plus fragiles
mais aussi des classes moyennes je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Thomas Cazenave rapporteur de
la commission des affaires économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous voici à nouveau réunis pour
examiner en nouvelle lecture cette
proposition de loi qui doit permettre de
prolonger le plafonnement à hauteur de 3
et demi pour cent de la variation
annuelle des deux indices locatifs qui
sont utilisés pour revaloriser les
loyers l'indice des loyers commerciaux
d'une part pour les beaux commerçants
commerçants et des artisans le
plafonnement ne valant que pour les
seuls petites et moyennes entreprises
l'indice de référence des loyers d'autre
part pour les loyers du parc privé et du
parc social je rappelle les raisons qui
ont motivé le dépôt de cette proposition
de loi nous avions voté dans la loi
pouvoir d'achat à l'été dernier un
premier plafonnement provisoire de ces
deux indices locatifs afin d'éviter une
envolée des loyers liés à la hausse de
l'inflation ce dispositif arrive à
échéance car il s'applique uniquement
jusqu'à la publication de l'IMC du
premier trimestre 2023 et de l'IRL du
deuxième trimestre 2023
or compte tenu des prévisions
d'inflation dont nous disposons à ce
jour il est nécessaire de prolonger à
nouveau la mesure jusqu'au premier
trimestre 2024 pour continuer de
protéger les locataires les commerçants
et les artisans puisque l'lc l'IRL ne
repasserait sous la barre des trois et
demi pour cent qu'au second trimestre de
la même année alors que l'Assemblée
nationale c'était mobilisée dans des
délais particulièrement bref pour
adopter ce texte en première lecture le
Sénat a rejeté le texte la semaine
dernière je regrette bien évidemment ce
rejet qui a logiquement conduit à faire
échouer la commission mixte paritaire
entre nos deux assemblées la semaine
dernière et nous amène à examiner ce
texte en nouvelle lecture j'en viens au
principal raisons avancées par la
Chambre haute pour justifier ce rejet en
premier lieu c'est un problème de
méthode qui a largement été dénoncé par
les sénateurs
l'examen du texte s'est fait dans des
délais très contraints dans chaque
chambre et il a été regretté l'absence
de mesure d'évaluation et d’études
d'impact sur ces différents arguments je
rappelle que la proposition de loin a
pour seul et unique objet de prolonger
une mesure conjoncturelle nous ne créons
aucune mesure nouvelle par
l'intermédiaire de cette proposition de
loi que le bien fondé de la mesure est
donc son évaluation ne fait aucun doute
lorsqu'on constate qu'en l'absence de
mesure de plafonnement l'il.c aurait dû
s'établir à plus 6,29% variation
annuelles au quatrième trimestre 2022 et
l'IRL a plus 6,26% au premier trimestre
2023 et donc son évaluation ne fait
aucun doute
que ces délais d'examens contraints
s'expliquent par le fait que le
plafonnement cessera bientôt de
s'appliquer et qu'il nous faut à tout
prix sécuriser locataire commerçant et
artisans qui sont en attente de cette
prolongation enfin la brièveté des
délais d'examen ne nous a pas empêché de
consulter les acteurs concernés au
travers des auditions que j'ai réalisées
en plus des multiples alertes que nous
avons également pu avoir dans nos
circonscriptions quant à l'échéance du
dispositif cela ne nous a pas empêché
d'avoir le débat à l'Assemblée en
première lecture en commission comme un
séance en second lieu les conséquences
défavorables de la mesure pour les
propriétaires ont été largement relayées
au Sénat il est indéniable que le
plafonnement des loyers impacte leurs
revenus locatif et représente un manque
à gagner alors même que les besoins
d'investissement sont massifs notamment
pour réussir le défi de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et que la taxe
foncière a augmenté dans un certain
nombre de villes c'est précisément c'est
précisément pour pour cela que nous
souhaitons strictement maintenir le
dispositif tel qu'il a été voté l'année
dernière dans la loi pour un achat sans
toucher sans toucher ni au plafonnement
ni à son champ d'application nous
intervenons directement dans un contrat
alors même que le droit de propriété et
la liberté contractuelle sont
strictement encadrés par notre
Constitution c'est cette recherche
d'équilibre qui explique mon opposition
un gel des loyers ou encore à étendre le
plafonnement de l'lc à toutes les
entreprises ces deux mesures
conduiraient un déséquilibre trop
important dans la relation contractuelle
à l'inverse un plafonnement de 3,8% pour
les ménages ainsi que pour les plus
petits commerces et économiquement
cohérent tant avec les prévisions
d'inflation qu'avec les capacités
financières dont dispose chacun pour
supporter les conséquences de cette
hausse des prix mais je défends
également une stricte prolongation de ce
mécanisme car je ne veux prendre aucun
risque de voir ce texte de loi censuré
par le Conseil constitutionnel ceux qui
priverait dès lors les bénéficiaires de
toute protection pour les mois à venir
enfin au cours des discussions sur cette
proposition de loi j'ai entendu certains
sur nos bancs demander à ce que nous
aboutissions à une position de compromis
sur le niveau de plafonnement à un
niveau inférieur à 3,5%. mais je le
répète cette position de compromis c'est
celle que nous avons déjà trouvé l'année
dernière justement à 3,5% lors du vote
de la loi pouvoir d'achat entre entre
des prévisions d'évolution des indices
qui dépassent les 6% et un gel pur et
simple nous maintenant une position
d'équilibre
en dernier lieu la rapporteur au Sénat a
dénoncé le manque d'ambition
structurelle du gouvernement en matière
de politique du logement mais cette
proposition de loi chers collègues n'a
jamais eu pour objectif de réformer la
politique du logement elle a uniquement
pour objet de permettre rapidement la
prolongation d'un dispositif de soutien
conjoncturel l'adoption indispensable
des mesures dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui ne doit pas être remise en
question sur le fondement de désaccord
qui dépassent très largement le
périmètre de cette proposition de loi en
conclusion notre débat est simple il y a
d'un côté ce qui souhaite le gel des
loyers cette position je la pense
injuste pour de nombreux propriétaires
qui sont aussi frappés par l'inflation
auxquelles nous demandons la rénovation
thermique des logements et qui ont vu
leurs impôts fonciers fortement augmenté
elle est également risquée sur le plan
juridique car le gel et loyers serait
très probablement censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel de l'autre
nous avons ceux qui ne veulent rien
faire ce qui aurait pour conséquence
d'augmenter les loyers de près de 7% des
juillet cette position est également
injuste car dangereuse pour le pouvoir
d'achat des locataires et
fragiliseraient grandement notre tissu
économique la commission des affaires
économiques a adopter le texte en
nouvelle lecture la semaine dernière
sans modification et je souhaite que nos
débats de ce jour permettent de parvenir
au même résultat je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
nous en venons à la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur William
Martinez pour le groupe la France
insoumise nupes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues nous entamons
la deuxième lecture d'une loi macroniste
qui propose de fixer à 3,5 % la révision
annuelle des indices locatifs je
voudrais rappeler ici les conséquences
sociales d'une telle proposition de loi
si elle était adoptée en l'état autorisé
une hausse de 3,5% qui s'ajoute à la
hausse du même niveau voté en juillet
dernier cela ferait une augmentation de
7% en un an c'est quasiment un treizième
mois de loyer que les locataires
auraient à payer malgré cela la macronie
ose parler d'une loi de plafonnement des
loyers mais chers collègues si vous
considérez que cette loi plafonne les
loyers alors je vous invite au plus vite
à déposer une proposition de loi de
plafonnement des salaires parce que plus
7% en deux mois il y a beaucoup de
travailleurs qui aimeraient bénéficier
d'un tel plafonnement de leurs revenus
plus sérieusement
si je fais référence au salaire c'est
parce que la proposition de loi que nous
discutons arrive dans un contexte bien
particulier l'inflation est généralisée
le prix du caddie au supermarché a
augmenté de 20%, les charges ont explosé
en suivant les prix de l'énergie bref
tout augmente tout sauf les salaires les
Français sont pris entre le marteau de
l'inflation et l'enclume des salaires
qui stagnent il faut dire que cette
situation est le résultat d'une
politique d'une politique que la
macronie et le rassemblement national
mène main dans la main ensemble vous
avez refusé une hausse significative du
SMIC ensemble vous avez refusé le
blocage des prix ensemble vous avez
refusé l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation sur ces sujets Macron Le Pen
c'est blanc bonnet et Blonay et bonnet
blanc
les profiteurs de crise vous disent
merci mais pas les français qui sont
dans le rouge à partir du 10 du mois
revenons-en au sujet du logement là
aussi il existe une alliance entre la
macronie et le RN elle a été scellée en
novembre dernier lors de la discussion
sur la proposition de loi kasbarium
berger je rappelle que cette loi
accélère les expulsions et aggrave les
peines contre les locataires qui
n'arrivent pas à payer leur loyer elle a
été dénoncée jusqu'à L'ONU qui a vu une
criminalisation de la pauvreté et bien
lors des discussions sur cette loi alors
que nous abordions les articles les plus
répressifs la minorité présidentielle
c'est fracturé et elle a eu besoin des
voix du rassemblement national pour
faire passer son texte ce jour est
marqué du saut de l'infamie se vote a
été l'acte de naissance du syndicat du
crime social que vous représentez RN et
macrony vous êtes des propagateurs de la
misère et vous trouverez toujours devant
vous la nuit pêche qui va résister qui
défendra les droits fondamentaux et
notamment le droit au logement je vais
poursuivre en citant Victor Hugo c'est
de l'enfer des pauvres qui est fait le
paradis des riches c'est vrai si vous
maltraitez le locataire c'est bien parce
que vous êtes au service des
multi-propriétaires rappelons quelques
réalités sociologiques les locataires
sont plus jeunes et plus modestes que le
reste de la population et inversement
les multipropriétaires sont plus âgés
plus riches et leur patrimoine et
majoritairement constitué par l'héritage
disons aussi que la propriété lucrative
est très concentrée 3,5% des métages
seulement des tiennes la moitié des
logements mis en location ces chiffres
nous amènent à une conclusion implacable
augmenter fortement les indices locatifs
comme vous le proposez est une mesure
inégalitaire c'est servir la soupe aux
héritiers et aux rentiers c'est à les
contre l'intérêt des Français qui
travaillent dur pour payer leur loyer
dernier sujet vous nous dites cette loi
n'a pas vocation à remplacer une grande
loi d'orientation de la politique du
logement très bien mais comme vous ne
gagnez pas ni vous ni le gouvernement
nous présenter une telle loi permettait
qu'on se saisisse de l'occasion pour
s'exprimer le CNR logement a provoqué un
mécontentement généralisé de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre au promoteur
immobilier tout le monde était mécontent
vous avez annoncé un nouveau plan
d'austérité après les 6 milliards déjà
ponctionnés sur les APL et les bailleurs
sociaux lors du précédent quinquennat
vous justifiez cela au nom de la
politique de l'offre j'en résume l'idée
laissons les investisseurs immobiliers
s'enrichir cela finira bien par
ruisseler sur les mâles logés et bien
malheureusement les chiffres vous
donnent tort le bilan de ces six
dernières années votre bilan est
accablant effondrement de la production
de logements record du nombre de 100
abris et explosion du nombre de
demandeurs de logements social votre
politique de l'offre en réalité c'est
une politique de la spéculation du
logement cher et du mal engagement à la
nupes nous proposons une politique
alternative pour le logement qui donne
toute sa place à la puissance publique
pour investir et pour réguler notamment
en baissant les loyers et on a en
encadrant les prix du foncier faute de
temps je ne pourrai détailler ses
propositions mais je conclus mon propos
sur une mesure modeste raisonnable qui
consiste à geler les loyers alors je
m'adresse au collègue macronistes vous
pouvez faire la bascule lors de ce vote
s'il vous plaît soyez raisonnable pensez
au locataire en difficulté lâchez la
main du RN et voter en faveur de notre
amendement qui gèlera les loyers je vous
remercie monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Lionel Tivoli
pour le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la Présidente chers collègue la
crise actuelle du logement et le
résultat de la folie des technocrates
c'est la consternation qui nous accable
devant une nouvelle loi rustine de votre
majorité pour venir au secours de ce
gouvernement preuve d'un manque de
vision preuve d'un manque d'anticipation
qui serait risible s'il ne s'agissait
pas d'un sujet aussi grave pour nos
compatriotes en l'espace de 6 ans nous
avons été témoins de votre incompétence
en l'espace de 6 ans vous avez été fendu
tout vous avez défendu tout et son
contraire sur tous les sujets
aujourd'hui face à une crise du logement
une poussée inflationniste sans
précédent vous Briez vous brillez par
votre incapacité à vous remettre en
question
l'accumulation des règles l'accumulation
des lois qui se superposent et se
contredisent parfois des normes toujours
plus contraignantes et bien entendu la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation ces
éléments auront rendu le marché du
logement inaccessible au classement
moyenne le précédent président de la
République mentor d'Emmanuel Macron
avait fait la promotion de sa boîte à
outils et il semble que vous vous en
soyez inspiré mais toujours sans avoir
fait l'effort de l'ouvrir vous êtes
quelque part les Monsieur Bricolage de
la politique
cette proposition de loi boucle les
loyers pour les ménages et les TPE PME a
été instaurés temporairement par la loi
dite pouvoir d'achat du 16 août 2022 et
parce que nous va vous n'arrivez
toujours pas à trouver de vraies
solutions pérennes vous la reconduisez
preuve que vous faites de la politique
au jour le jour
cette proposition de loi elle mérite de
révéler les positions et les
propositions de chacun face à cette
crise du logement et aux difficultés de
nos TPE Alain
UPS comme d'habitude vous opposez les
propriétaires et les locataires selon
vous les propriétaires seraient les
vilains riches qui abuseraient des
locataires mais savez-vous qu'il y a une
multitude de petits propriétaires qui
ont tant bien que mal placé leur petites
économies dans l'immobilier pour
améliorer leur maigre pension de
retraite que ce gouvernement n'a cessé
de mettre à mal ses cinq dernières
années vous proposez même de geler la
hausse des loyers ce qui est
économiquement intenable quant au LR ce
sujet ne semble visiblement pas vous
concerner étant à des années lumière des
préoccupations des ménages vos collègues
sénateurs ont tout simplement rejeté en
commission mixte paritaire cette
proposition de loi laissant les
propriétaires et les locataires prendre
l'inflation de plein fouet tout tremble
tous s'effondre mais chez les
républicains rien ne bouge
dans ce cas de figure vous laissez les
Français propriétaire et locataires
gérant de TPE PME sans solution
instantanée tout ce qui va dans le sens
des Français vous le refusez votez la
motion de censure pour bloquer le
gouvernement vous l'avez refusé et dès
les petits propriétaires et locataires à
sortir la spirale inflationniste vous le
refusez même le repas à neuro pour les
étudiants vous l'avez refusé pendant
pendant ce temps la majorité propose
comme d'habitude le en même temps un
coup à gauche un coup à droite on ne
sait désormais plus où donner de tête
les Français ne comprennent plus vos
accumulations de normes les Français ne
comprennent plus vos accumulations de
loi de décret d'incitation et surtout de
complications les Français ne peuvent
plus se loger les jeunes et les classes
moyennes ne peuvent plus accéder à la
propriété après avoir divisé nos
commerçants entre les essentiels et les
non essentiels après avoir obligé
certains commerçants à fermer vous
proposer des PGE qui le rembourse
aujourd'hui et qui les mettent en grosse
difficulté aujourd'hui la seule réponse
à ces fermetures c'est le blocage de
l'indice des loyers à 3,5%, bien sûr les
tendres ETI et malgré ça vous vous
contentez de mesurer vous avancez à
tantôt parce que vous avez peur vous
semblez n'avoir pas compris que la
France a besoin d'une réforme profonde
d'une réforme structurelle d'une vision
globale en matière de logement vision
que nous on rassemblement national nous
défendons une vision globale une région
structurelle pour répandre à la crise du
logement en trois axes tout en
supprimant vos normes inutiles qui
freinent l'accès au logement une
révision de la fiscalité notamment des
prés d'appâts au zéro des mesures
d'exonération des jeunes de moins de 30
ans des sur les donations pour faciliter
les transmissions et un abattement plus
important sur les successions de biens
immobiliers l'aménagement du territoire
est notamment avec un contrat
gagnant-gagnant pour repeupler la
diagonale du vide avec des logements
abordables pour nos concitoyens une
politique de rénovation énergétique
incitative et non pas punitive comme
vous le proposez alors bien évidemment
que nous voterons votre texte puisqu'on
rassemblement national nous sommes
cohérents et nous avons toujours dit que
nous voterons même la plus petite mesure
qui permettrait
l'amélioration du cadre de vie de nos
concitoyens mais nous vous demandons
d'arrêter les mesures de colmatage afin
d'avoir une vision globale et des
réponses structurelles aux besoins que
vivent les Français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur romain Daubié pour le groupe
démocrate modem et indépendant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous débattons d'une
proposition de loi qui vise à prolonger
le plafonnement de la variation de l'IRL
et du LC c'est-à-dire de limiter les
effets de l'inflation sur les loyers et
donc de donner du poids d'achat à nos
concitoyens et donc légitime de se poser
la question de bilan de la mesure voter
il y a un an afin de déterminer de sa
reconduction ou pas quel était
l'objectif initial tout simplement
lutter contre l'inflation sur le premier
poste des ménages à savoir le logement
et protéger nos artisans nos commerçants
et nos tissus de TPE et de PME c'est
disposition est un des boucliers
anti-inflation à la dispose de
disposition de nos concitoyens tout
comme Madame le miniser Grégoire les
boucliers tarifaires énergies ou le
panier anti-inflation
donc pas pour objectif de régler
l'ensemble des problèmes liés au
logement à la crise de construction ou
de l'accession ces grandes lois
structurelles viendra mais ce n'est pas
le sujet du jour
quels sont les avis des experts sur ces
mesures ce dispositif met en place
depuis un an à incontestablement protégé
les locataires d'une explosion des
loyers soutenu par l'inflation voilà par
exemple le retour objectif sur ces
dispositions de même la très sérieuse
étude clamer sur les loyers organise de
référence sur le sujet arrivent au même
conclusions cette organisme chiffre même
l'augmentation moyenne des loyers à 1,3%
en 2022 ce qui correspond à la moyenne
des années précédentes alors que
l'inflation était plus faible sans ces
droits les loyers auraient pu augmenter
de plus de 6%. cela prouve que la mesure
votée a fonctionné et que la mesure est
bien un plafond et pas une augmentation
automatique non il ne s'agit pas de
voter en catimini une l'alimentation de
loyer de cerguments comme celui-là a pu
être affirmé sur une radio par une élue
et relayée avec une mauvaise foi
consternante par des députés tiktokers
non nous ne débattons pas ici d'une
mesure néolibérale favorisant les
sociétés foncières immobilières côté en
bourse nous débattons ici d'une mesure
équilibrée qui fixe un plafond maximum
pas une augmentation automatique nous
considérons au groupe démocrate tout
comme les experts indépendants que ces
dispositifs ont fait leurs preuves nous
sommes conscients des défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés en termes
d'inflation et de pression économique
mais nous sommes résolus à agir avec
détermination pour protéger les intérêts
des citoyens et l'économie nationale en
soutenant ces mesures nous visons à
atténuer les effets négatifs de
l'inflation sur les familles et sur les
entreprises tout en favorisant un
développement économique durable et
équilibré
c'est pourquoi mon groupe apportera son
soutien plein et entier aux mesures de
ce texte afin d'accompagner au plus près
les Français sous toutes sur toute la
durée de ce pic inflationniste pour
finir j'habite chacun à prendre ces
responsabilités le droit constitutionnel
ne permet pas de bloquer totalement les
loyers ce serait une attente évidente à
l'article 17 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et des citoyen du 26
août 1789 ce serait également une
injustice pour toute une catégorie de
personnes je pense au premier lieu
retraité qui compte sur un loyer pour
compléter leur retraite et je pense
également à tous les bailleurs privés
qui logent des millions de personnes et
qui vont engager des travaux de
rénovation je vous rappelle aussi que le
temps presse au 30 juin à minuit sans
nouvelle loi l'augmentation des loyers
non plafonnés reprendra ainsi les
personnes qui prétendraient défendre le
pouvoir d'achat des Français en
s'opposant à ce texte seront en réalité
à l'origine du retour des loyers des
plafonnés vous aurez alors une autre
responsabilité à endosser mettre les
locataires habitants du parc privé ou du
parc conventionné et nos commerçants en
difficulté seraient d'une rare
irresponsabilité oui il faut agir
concrètement oui face à au pique
d'inflation il faut protéger accompagner
les familles nos tissus d'artisans de
commerçants de PME oui il faut voter ce
texte je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Marie-Noëlle
Baptiste pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues pour la quatrième fois nous
sommes amenés à débattre de cette
proposition de loi dans sa version
initiale un texte qui vous l'aurez
compris monsieur le rapporteur ne
convient pas à notre groupe comme aux
autres groupes de la gauche nous avons
nous n'avons pas été convaincus ni par
vos arguments économiques ni par vos
arguments constitutionnels nous avions
mis en avant une simulation simple qui
rappelle que sur la période couverte par
la loi de juillet 2022
et celle à laquelle ce texte
s'appliquerait une augmentation cumulée
de 7,1% reviendrait à imposer au
locataire l'équivalent d'un mois de
loyer supplémentaires sur une année qui
s'ajoute à une hausse des charges sans
précédent et vous le savez bien nul
besoin de rappeler que sur la même
période les revenus des ménages n'ont
évidemment pas augmenté à proportion
d'un mois de salaire je crois que vous
en conviendrez à cela vous avez répondu
par un argument économique imbattable
les républicains proposent 6 % la nups
propose un gel de 0% donc vous avez donc
dit alors j'ai coupé la poire en deux en
vous proposant un compromis à 3,5%
votre jugement de Salomon monsieur le
rapporteur n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux ce n'est pas une mesure
d'équilibre que vous nous proposez
locataire et propriétaire ne sont pas et
ne seront jamais sur un même pied
d'égalité les premiers essaient de vivre
dignement dans leur logement les seconds
pour une large part recherche avant tout
une meilleure rentabilité de leur
investissement oui nous le savons il
existe de nombreux petits propriétaires
petit bailleur privé pas forcément aisé
des propriétaires retraités ou des
primo-accédants qui eux doivent
absolument être protégés si vous
acceptiez notre amendement de compromis
à 2%, il connaîtrait une hausse de leurs
revenus locatifs de 5,1% sur la période
largement de quoi couvrir l'évolution de
leur charge
cependant c'est oublier que 3% des
ménages possèdent la moitié du
patrimoine immobilier locatif et pour
ces ménages aisés votre proposition de
loi de plafonnement ne fait que
légèrement réduire le montant de leur
bénéfices rappelons tout de même que le
taux de retour sur investissement depuis
30 ans en France dans l'immobilier
locatif et de 8,8 % soit près du double
de l'assurance vie et qu'il se situe
quasiment au même taux que pour les
placements en bourse il dépasse même ces
derniers sur la période récente donc non
il ne faut pas sanctionner les petits
propriétaires monsieur le rapporteur
mais il ne faut pas sacrifier leur
locataire sur l'hôtel de la rentabilité
immobilière des grands détenteurs de
bien un gel des loyers locatifs serait
nécessaire en attendant un rattrapage du
pouvoir d'achat des ménages celui-ci
vous semble constitutionnellement
incertain nous pouvons l'entendre
partisan du compromis nous avons donc
des prosolutions de compromis à 1% et
même à 2%. ces propositions sont défendu
par notre groupe permet de retrouver un
trop d'évolution proche du taux
d'inflation constaté par l'INSEE en 2022
et donc parfaitement défendable autant
devant les sages que devant les Français
cet amendement constitue un point
d'équilibre meilleur que le vôtre
monsieur le rapporteur qui nous
amènerait à soutenir ce texte car nous
devons être sur un compromis dans
l'intérêt des Français la crise du
logement atteint des niveaux
exceptionnels matérialisés par le Front
uni de l'ensemble des acteurs de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre à la Fédération
des promoteurs immobiliers contre la
faiblesse des conclusions et des
propositions
issues du cnr-l logement nageons pas aux
difficultés structurelles des problèmes
conjoncturels avec une surconstruction
des ménages locataires locataire alors
monsieur le rapporteur une dernière fois
nous vous appelons à la raison à la
pondération faites un effort de justice
sociale en faveur des locataires en
abaissant le taux d'évolution plafonné à
défaut de le gelée vous pourrez alors
compter sur l'ensemble des députés
socialistes pour porter votre texte
jusqu'à son adoption définitive dans le
contraire et bien nous serons contraints
de voter contre et nous continuerons de
défendre les locataires face à hausse
abusives et apporter un projet politique
sensiblement différent du vôtre je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Luc lamiro pour le
groupe horizon et à parenté
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques mes chers collègues nous
sommes un nouveau réuni pour examiner
une nouvelle lecture la proposition de
loi qui vise à maintenir provisoirement
le dispositif de plafonnement de
revalorisation de la variation annuelle
des indices locatifs
l'objectif est donc de maintenir le
dispositif de plafonnement
des de l'indice des loyers locatifs
pardon et de celui des références des
loyers mis en place pour une durée d'un
an par les articles 12 et 14 de la loi
pouvoir d'achat
du 16 août dernier et qui devait
s'arrêter
à la fin juin et nous proposons ici de
le prolonger jusqu'à l'année du premier
trimestre de l'année 2024 pardon
plus précisément
l'article premier vise à prolonger le
plafonnement fixé à 3,5% de
l'augmentation des indices des loyers
afin de permettre au PME de garder la
tête hors de l'eau et ainsi de préserver
la diversité de notre tissu commercial
en effet le loyer représente une part
importante dans les charges des
entreprises et peut représenter jusqu'à
20% du chiffre d'affaires pour certains
commerces le contexte inflationniste
pourrait conduire à des niveaux de
variation annuelles basées sur les 6% de
l'inflation soit des niveaux très
supérieurs aux 3,5% que nous proposons
l'article de Dieu m'a deux maintient le
plafonnement temporaire de
3,5% de l'augmentation de l'indice de
référence des loyers pour les ménages
cette fois-ci afin de les aider à lutter
contre l'inflation actuelle et qui
d'après les prévisions de l'Insee va
perdurer jusqu'en début 2024 ce plafond
permet au locataire d'avoir une hausse
de loyer moins importante que celle qui
aurait été appliquée à partir du 1er
juillet
2023 c'est-à-dire 6%
. adopté en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale cette proposition
de loi a malheureusement été rejeté par
nos collègues sénateurs je regrette que
la commission mixte paritaire n'est pas
pu permettre de permettre de trouver un
accord entre nos deux chambres malgré
l'urgence du sujet et l'importance du
maintien des mesures
si nous avons pas les différer dès le
mois de janvier tel que les sénateurs
nous l'ont reproché c'est bien parce
qu'en janvier nous espérions que
l'inflation marque le pas
au-delà du plafonnement que
au-delà du plafonnement que j'espère
nous voterons une réflexion sur l'indice
des loyers commerciaux me semble
nécessaire en effet il s'agit d'un
indicateur national qui ne correspond
pas toujours à la situation de certaines
de nos petites villes et de l'évolution
du commerce en centre-ville dans le
cadre du Conseil national du commerce
que vous avez initié madame la ministre
il semblerait judicieux d'envisager une
territorialisation de ce dernier en
fonction de la taille des communes de
leur situation géographique et du type
d'activité cela permettrait ainsi
davantage de davantage refléter la
réalité de nos territoires et ainsi
soutenir les commerces de nos centres
bourg
dans l'immédiat nous ne devons de voter
ce texte afin d'empêcher une hausse
importante des loyers des juillet et si
ce dispositif n'était pas maintenu ce
serait le cas
soucieux de protéger à la fois les
petits entreprises et les locataires
d'une inflation qui malheureusement a
maintenu son niveau le groupe Horizon
est apparenté réitère son soutien total
à cette proposition de loi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame la Présidente Cyrielle châtelain
pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission chers collègues ce n'est pas
si souvent que la vie nous offre une
seconde chance il y a seulement deux
semaines de ça dans cette émission nous
avons cherché à vous convaincre qu'il
était possible de geler les loyers et
vous avez laissé passer l'occasion
l'augmentation des loyers aujourd'hui
alors qu'on est dans une phase
d'inflation énorme est une difficulté
pour de trop nombreux de nos concitoyens
je l'ai les loyers c'est leur donner un
tout petit peu d'air parce que derrière
le taux d'inflation derrière les indices
de référence de loyer ce sont des
personnes qui payent à payer leur
logement il y a une détresse sociale
vis-à-vis social vis-à-vis du logement
dans ce pays vous ne l'entendez pas
mais non ce qu'on vous dit c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus 3,5 l'année dernière
plus 5,5 cette année c'est ce n'est pas
supportable mais je comprends que vous
ne l'entendiez pas parce qu'a priori
votre politique du logement c'est quand
même un zéro pointé je suis désolé de
vous le dire monsieur le ministre il y a
deux semaines on avait encore un peu
l'illusion parce qu'il y avait le CNR
qui devait apporter ses conclusions et
malgré de dire c'est un échec c'est un
échec la seule réussite des conclusions
de ce CNR c'est de mettre l'intégralité
des acteurs du logement contre la
politique du gouvernement les
conclusions de ce CNR c'est en fait ce
CNR c'est 200 personnes utiliser des
dizaines de réunions la production de
trois rapports et une nouvelle fois
finalement vous avez fait la
démonstration que vous n'avez rien à
proposer et pour ça je veux prendre
juste les commentaires qui ont été faits
par les acteurs du logement pour
l'ensemble des acteurs le sentiment d'un
rendez-vous manqué la montagne à cause
d'une souris tout un secteur méprisé
inquiétude sur le logement social CNR
logement les professionnels expriment
leurs colères les annonces provoquent la
déception c'est un c'est un extrait de
florilège de mauvais commentaires sur
les conclusions de son CNR je me paierai
quand même de si tu es encore deux
personnes la Fondation Abbé Pierre le
délégué général qui dit que pendant plus
de six mois il a CO animé le CNR il dit
avoir un sentiment de gueule de bois et
il précise qu'il a des gros inquiétudes
qui subissent sur le projet et en finale
ce sont l'Association des Maires
d'Île-de-France qui en parlent le mieux
de ce cnr- qui compte plus de 1,3
millions de mal logés sur le territoire
ils n'y ont vu je cite qu'une liste de
mesurettes décevantes
de vente l'envers de ces mesures est
nous a été annoncé hier soir lors des
Assises des finances publiques après la
baisse des aPL après la baisse des
moyens des organismes HLM et alors que
le PIB consacré par les pouvoirs publics
aujourd'hui sur la politique de logement
et de 1,5 % du PIB soit le niveau le
plus bas jamais atteint depuis 40 ans
Bruno Le Maire nous annonce que le
gouvernement compte faire encore 2
milliards d'économies sur les politiques
du logement 2 milliards d'économies
alors qu'un quart des Français sont
touchés par la crise du logement que 2,4
millions de personnes sont en attente de
logement sociaux que non de famille
s'envoient de paupérisation au niveau en
raison du niveau du poids du loyer et du
poids des charges c'est inconscient
quand il s'agit de votre politique du
logement on n'attend plus grand chose et
en vrai même si la formule est éculée
oui en fait on est quand même déçu c'est
quand même assez dingue cette création
cruciale pour de nombreux Français cette
majorité relative n'est pas auteur il
n'y a aucune politique il n'y a aucune
vision il n'y a aucune proposition vous
n'avez à nous proposer qu'une loi unique
c'est-à-dire la loi dite
anti-squats et un faux bouclier social
dans cette proposition de loi le seul
beau pied social c'est le gel des loyers
et puisque vous nous demandez des
propositions monsieur le rapporteur
faites ces propositions ils sont et que
nous faisons notre ce sont les
propositions des membres du CNR que vous
avez fait travailler pendant ces 6 mois
je vous le dis convertir semi-long
logements en deux ans envahir réel
solidaire faciliter la reconversion des
pls en PLS c'est à dire il faut logement
social dans du logement très social
créer une allocation mondiale pour
garantir un plafond de 25% maximum du
taux d'effort des déménages ça veut dire
ne pas mettre plus de 25% de son budget
dans son loyer ajuster le loyer de
référence APL sur les loyers Patrick et
introduire une taxe sur la ségrégation
urbaine encadrer les prix du foncier
apporter une oeuvre supplémentaire de
logement abordable pour loger les
fonctionnaires limiter la plus-value sur
les logements dans la valeur est
directement liée à l'investissement
public il y en a des dizaines et des
dizaines des propositions dans le
travail qui ont été faits par l'ensemble
des acteurs du logement ce ne sont donc
pas les idées qui nous vont qui vous
manquent les idées ces acteurs là vous
les ont donné sur un plateau ce ne sont
pas les solutions qui manquent c'est
l'argent aujourd'hui vous préférez
baisser les infos des grandes
entreprises et des plus riches plutôt
que d'investir pour le logement donc
aujourd'hui la situation est extrêmement
claire il y a deux solutions soit vous
geler les loyers pour enfin protéger les
locataires et vous pouvez compter sur
nous soit si finalement c'est pour vous
compter sur nous pour mettre un peu plus
la tête sous l'eau à ceux et celles qui
ne cherchent qu'un tout petit peu d'air
et bien dans ces cas-là nous
continuerons à voter contre cette
proposition de loi
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
à Monsieur Thibaut Bazin pour le groupe
les républicains
merci Madame la présidence monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous examinons en nouvelle
lecture la proposition de loi visant à
maintenir pendant une année
supplémentaire le plafonnement de la
revalorisation annuelle des indices
locatifs après que le Sénat a rejeté en
séance publique et en commission mixte
pourquoi ce rejet en première lecture
les sénateurs ont d'abord mis en avant
un problème de méthode ils ont dressé le
quintuple constat d'une impréparation
d'une précipitation d'une absence
d'évaluation d'un manque de concertation
et d'un accompagnement financier des
acteurs pour reprendre les mots de la
rapporteur mais un Estrosi ça sonne nous
vous avions d'ailleurs alerté monsieur
mini sur ses points en première lecture
ici même le groupe les républicains
regrettent ainsi le manque
d'anticipation qui entoure ce texte et
qui nous oblige à l'examiner dans la
précipitation par le biais d'une
procédure simplifiée le gouvernement
semble s'être aperçu tardivement que le
plafonnement à 3,5% de la variation de
ces indices que nous avions voté dans le
cadre de la loi du 16 août 2022 portant
en mesure d'urgence pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat allez s'éteindre ce
30 juin ce n'est pas très sérieux ce
texte est surtout révélateur de
l'incapacité du gouvernement à répondre
à des questions essentielles où est
l'évaluation des mesures prises en
dernier pas de réponse ce n'est pourtant
pas anodin car le coup du plafonnement
de la hausse de l'IRL pour les
propriétaires avait été évalué à 705
millions d'euros pour 2022 à combien
s'est élevé dans les faits
l'augmentation des loyers des locaux
commerciaux pas de réponse quels sont
les coûts et les conséquences de ces
mesures pour les propriétaires privés et
les bailleurs sociaux pas davantage de
réponse comme l'a dit la présidente de
la commission des affaires économiques
du Sénat Sophie prima vous nous demandez
de voter non seulement à la sauvette
mais aussi à l'aveuglette cela étant
déploré sur la forme venons-en au fond
vous nous proposez concrètement de
renouveler pour une durée de 12 mois le
plafonnement de la revérialisation de
l'indice de référence des loyers à 3,5%.
alors que la hausse de l'IRL avoisine 6%
pour ne pas tromper les Français qu'on
vient de préciser qu'il s'agit d'un
plafonnement à 3 et demi non pas sur
deux ans mais qui s'applique chaque
année face à une inflation persistante
nous partageons l'idée que les familles
et les commerçants doivent être protégés
et accompagnés oui il faut agir mais
nous émettons pour autant certaines
réserves il nous faut rechercher une
répartition la plus juste de l'effort en
veillant à ne pas trop complexifier un
secteur déjà bien Mané en effet si votre
plafonnement ne l'avait l'apparition de
l'IRL permet à première vue de protéger
efficacement les locataires il fait fi
de l'inflation que subissent aussi de
leur côté les bailleurs bailleurs privés
comme socio petit ou gros loin des idées
reçues ces bailleurs peuvent aussi être
des propriétaires modestes qui mettent
en location un bien durement acquis et
qui devront par ailleurs faire face à de
coûteux travaux énergétiques dans les
prochaines années s'il veut maintenir ce
bien dans le parc locatif ils ont
parfois contracté des emprunts le coût
de la dette comme des travaux augmente
il en va de même pour les taxes
foncières
nous ne pouvons pas le nier il faut
aussi le prendre en compte face à
l'inflation nous souhaitons comme vous
protéger les locataires mais il faudrait
aussi accompagner les propriétaires il
serait par exemple intéressant de
prévoir de manière corollaire des
compensations de ces pertes de recettes
pour les bailleurs cela pourrait prendre
la forme de réduction d'impôts car au
moment où notre pays est confronté à une
crise du logement qui se traduit par une
demande croissante de logement à la fois
qualitative et quantitative il faut
avoir conscience que ce plafonnement qui
n'est ni plus ni moins qu'une perte de
recettes potentielle pour les bailleurs
va les contraintes madame la ministre
dans leur capacité de construction et de
rénovation nous risquons pas de pousser
les bailleurs à reporter des travaux
notamment énergétiques qui permettrait
de baisser les charges des locataires
par la suite attention donc à ne pas
poursuivre des objectifs contradictoires
ne risque-t-on pas de décourager les
investisseurs dans la pierre alors que
si on encourageait davantage la
construction la rénovation on
augmenterait l'offre de logement ce qui
diminuerait la pression immobilière au
bénéfice des locataires par ailleurs il
nous semble que votre texte souffre
d'une lacune qui pourrait empêcher
opérationnellement de protéger tous nos
petits commerçants en effet vous
entendez plafonner d'une part l'IRL est
l'irlc autrement dit vous ne faites pas
mention de l'ICC l'indice de coupe de
construction des immeubles à usage
d'habitation qui est pourtant aussi
utilisé dans les baux commerciaux
pendantccadrer la revérialisation des
loyers ne serait-il pas opportun de
corriger cette mission par ailleurs en
prolongeant purement et simplement le
dispositif actuel vous faites l'économie
d'une évaluation des effets constatés
après la mise en oeuvre de ce
plafonnement combien de logements ont
été sortis du marché locatif classique
combien de logements ont vu leur projet
de rénovation reporter bien sûr l'accès
au crédit joue également il dépend de la
capacité financière des acteurs et des
règles en vigueur qui conviendraient de
modifier pour conclure les députés les
républicains soutiendront les mesures
pour protéger les locataires face à
l'inflation en espérant que la navette
parlementaire permet d'améliorer cette
profession de loi il nous reste quelques
jours d'ici 30 juin pour bâtir le dis
positif le plus équilibré possible afin
d'accompagner également les
propriétaires face à l'invasion et
relever le défi de la transition
énergétique il y a urgence mes chers
collègues à agir et il faudra d'autres
mesures que celles prévues dans cette
proposition de loi merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de commission monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue comment obtenir
jusqu'à la fin du mois alors que tout
augmente c'est la question que se pose
effectivement nous concitoyens
l'inflation a fait que leur quotidien et
les rangs jour après jour plus
vulnérables vulnérables face au prix
d'alimentation des transports des
assurances de l'énergie qui atteignent
des sommets vulnérables en raison de
revenus trop faibles vulnérables car une
fois les dépenses essentielles réglées
un Français sur 3 se retrouve avec moins
de 100 euros dès le 10 du mois dans ces
conditions comment faire face à la
dépense imprévue à la panne de voiture
ou encore la nouvelle hausse de loyer
cette situation insoutenable nous devons
la garder à l'esprit avec le bouclier
cette année comme en 2022 les loyers
augmenteront quand même de 3,5%
certains diront que c'est un moindre mal
que sans cette proposition de loi la
hausse aurait été de 6% au minimum mais
pour ceux qui vivent les fins de mois
difficiles c'est déjà trop c'est ce que
peut c'est ce que peut faire basculer
d'ailleurs dans une certaine précarité
alors nous disons OUI au bouclier mais
il devrait être accompagné d'une
revalorisation des aides personnelles au
logement au minimum pour accompagner
d'abord les plus fragiles qu'attend le
gouvernement pour le faire une nouvelle
crise sociale une dégradation des
situations économiques nous savons aussi
nos PME connaissent une sortie de crise
progressive mais leur situation reste
délicate une augmentation soudaine des
loyers pourrait faire peser un risque
important sur leur finance dans un
contexte d'augmentation des coûts et
d'une consommation qui n'est pas au
rendez-vous
en réalité limiter les hausses des
loyers n'est qu'une réponse partielle et
de court terme la France doit répondre
aux problèmes beaucoup plus larges de la
crise du logement c'était rappelé par
les collègues cette proposition de loi
je pense n'y répondre à pas elle a été
d'abord présentée dans l'urgence sans
études d'impact ni consultation des
acteurs du secteur à croire que Bercy a
découvert le 23 mai que le bouclier
loyer prendrait fin le 30 juin tout cela
est assez révélateur de votre
considération pour les plus fragilisés
une attitude représentative de votre
politique du logement depuis 2017 vous
êtes dans une approche comptable et
budgétaire qui aggravent les difficultés
des acteurs du secteur au risque de nous
conduire droit dans le mur du côté du
secteur privé vous n'avez eu de 16 de
raboter ou de supprimer des dispositifs
d'aide à la construction adieu l'aide
aux mères bâtisseurs le dispositif Pinel
bientôt à loint à souvenir quant au PTZ
au prêt à taux zéro il n'est plus que
l'ombre de lui-même les conséquences de
cette politique sont visibles la
construction traverse une crise et une
crise grave le nombre de réservations
auprès des promoteurs est tombé au
niveau du printemps 2020 au cœur de la
crise sanitaire voyez l'ampleur du
marasme
du côté du logement social le bilan des
guerres plus reluisant dans la
continuité du quinquennat précédent vous
avez décidé de prolonger la réduction du
loyer de solidarité une ponction sur les
ressources donc des organismes HLM à
hauteur de 1,3 milliards par an résultat
les dépenses d'entretien baisse la
rénovation énergétique des logements
sociaux est entravés et la construction
la construction neuve chute qu'a prévu
le Conseil national de la refondation
pour inverser la tendance c'était
rappelé aussi par mes collègues de la
vie générale il n'a pas été à la hauteur
des enjeux ces conclusions témoignent
d'une incompréhension du secteur nous
atteignons tous un changement handicap
où est passé la promesse du président de
la République d'un choc de l'offre nous
n'avons que de que quelques mesurettes
recyclage et rabotages d'anciens
dispositifs alors que la crise du
logement est là sous nos yeux et cette
proposition de loi ne permettrait pas à
mon avis d'inverser la tendance nous la
voterons néanmoins puisqu'elle quelque
part limite en fin de compte les dégâts
on va dire dans l'espoir que le
gouvernement s'engage à revaloriser pour
celles et ceux qui ont le plus besoin
les aides au logement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame anaïg Lemeur pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des
affaires économiques monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues je vais pas
vous faire de mon discours à Fourtou du
tout et du n'importe quoi je vous
rappelle le contexte car certains ici
semblent avoir oublié
la dernière le Parlement s'est été saisi
de la question du pouvoir d'achat et
avait réussi à s'accorder pour limiter
la hausse des loyers à plus 3,5% pour
l'ensemble des Français nous avions bien
fait de voter ces mesures d'urgence car
la France a connu une inflation sans
précédent ces mesures d'urgence ont
permis de protéger le pouvoir d'achat de
nos compatriotes de protéger nos
commerçants et nos entreprises les plus
fragiles
car oui mes chers collègues soyons
honnêtes sans ces mesures les Français
reconnus une hausse généralisée de leur
loyer de l'ordre de plus 6,3% en moyenne
contre + 3,5% grâce à nous
et pourtant nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui à devoir revoter ce texte
après une commission mixte paritaire non
conclusive suite au rejet du texte par
le Sénat alors que nous souhaitons
prolonger jusqu'au premier trimestre
2024 de plateforme des loyers certains
groupes politiques préfèrent jouer avec
le feu et risquer une explosion des prix
du loyer sans pour autant en assumer les
conséquences politiques et humaines
la question n'est pas de poser les
locataires et les propriétaires de
manière manichéenne tous les
propriétaires ne sont pas fortunés
certains subissent aussi les
conséquences de la crise tous les
locataires ne vivent pas dans la misère
tout est une question d'équilibre ce
sont les postures les caricatures
nous souhaitons protéger les
propriétaires et les locataires ont
votant un texte utile bénéfique et
équilibré ce test permettra de répartir
le poids de l'inflation entre les
différents acteurs et de protéger les
acteurs les plus fragiles
ceux qui s'y opposeront devront assumer
une augmentation massive des loyers dans
les prochains mois
je tiens donc au nom du groupe
Renaissance à réaffirmer notre souhait
de reconduire un dispositif équilibré
plutôt que de geler les loyers ou encore
d'étendre les mesures à d'autres
entreprises aussi j'appelle chacun des
députés présents ce soir à voter en
toute responsabilité ce soir il ne tient
qu'à nous de ne pas aggraver la crise du
logement vont en ce texte qui a pour
seul vocation de prolonger le plafond de
l'indice des loyers
et oui chers collègues vous pouvez le
constater c'est notre groupe qui fait
force de propositions faisant des
propositions de loi relatives au
logement et nous sommes l'avons fait
l'avons assumé depuis le début de ce
mandat
donc je compte sur vous et je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
je ne vois pas le
monsieur d'accord je vous laisse arriver
je vous laisse arriver
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
dareville pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine nups
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la ministre
chers et chers collègues
je vais prononcer cette intervention au
nom de notre groupe et de mon collègue
Stéphane peu
une fois encore vous maltraitez le
Parlement une fois encore l'un
préparation et la précipitation
gouvernementale dont on ne sait si elles
sont une marque de fabrique ou le
résultat d'une intention délibérée nous
conduise à prolonger dans l'urgence sans
consultation sérieuse sans études
d'impact et même sans évaluation un
dispositif qui est une très mauvaise
réponse à une vraie question notre pays
connaît une crise considérable du
pouvoir d'achat crise qui frappe d'abord
les foyers les plus modestes
puisqu'elles résultent du décalage
défavorable entre le niveau des salaires
et des pensions d'une part et
d'explosion des prix d'autre part c'est
dans ce contexte de très grande tension
sociale que vous nous proposez
d'autoriser une nouvelle hausse de 3,5%
des loyers ceux des particuliers comme
ceux des petites entreprises en effet ce
que vous présentez comme un plafond
fonctionnera bien évidemment comme un
plancher puisque par son mode de calcul
même l'indice de référence des loyers
conduit à alimenter mécaniquement leur
OS votre proposition n'est donc pas un
bouclier tarifaire mais en vérité une
véritable
courroie de transmission inflationniste
au détriment des familles modestes vous
prétendez que ce dispositif
constituerait un point d'équilibre entre
d'une part la protection des bailleurs
et d'autre part celle des locataires
alors même qui ne subissent pas de façon
équilibrée les conséquences de cette
poussée inflationniste en effet vous
négligez totalement le fait que
l'essentiel des hausses intervenu ces
derniers mois et celui supporté par les
locataires
ceux du parc privé comme ceux du parc
social par l'intermédiaire des charges
qui sont directement reportées sur leur
quittance de loyer en particulier
l'électricité mais aussi le gaz qui a
augmenté de 68% en deux ans et dont en
plus les tarifs vont être dérégulés à
partir du 1er juillet prochain donc au
moment même où ils doivent affronter une
explosion de ces charges vous condamnez
une véritable double peine ces jeunes
ces travailleurs travailleuses de la
première ligne s'est retraités tous ces
foyers modestes pour lesquels faut-il
vous le rappeler le logement constitue
de très loin la principale dépenses
alors bien sûr vous aurez vos jeux de
nous faire remarquer que certains de nos
collègues sénateurs entendaient porter à
6% ce faux plafond nous échapperions
ainsi au pire décidément vous ne semblez
pas mesurer les conséquences dramatiques
du nouvel hausse des loyers sur ces
familles modestes dont le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le plus douloureusement
effondré en deux ans elle qui ont vu
l'an passé leur loyer augmenter elle à
qui on a déjà rogné les APL
chers et chers collègues dans cette
situation d'une exceptionnelle gravité
votre proposition est donc
rigoureusement inacceptable à nos yeux
nous vous mettons d'ailleurs en garde
contre son adoption et à la place nous
faisons une double proposition d'une
part il faut répondre à l'urgence pour
cela il faut un gel des loyers c'est la
seule véritable mise sous protection
possible quand quelqu'un se noie on lui
sort la tête de l'eau on ne discute pas
pour savoir à quel profondeur on doit le
laisser sur nager d'autre part votre
sollicitude à l'égard des bailleurs ne
dure que tant qu'elle vous permet de
reporter sur les locataires les efforts
sur les loyers et les charges si vous
voulez enfin prendre en compte les
difficultés des bailleurs compenser
auprès d'eux le gel des loyers que nous
proposons et quoi qu'il en soit modifier
le calcul de l'indice locatif pour le
décorréler de l'inflation l'autre niveau
de réponse c'est tout simplement de
retrouver une politique de logement dans
ce pays car la situation que nous
connaissons dans ce domaine ne résulte
ni de la guerre en Ukraine ni des
conséquences de la crise climatique
c'est bien l'impéricide nos politiques
publiques qui en est la cause notamment
l'effondrement de la production en j'ai
fait votre inconséquence se mesure pas
seulement au fait de découvrir que votre
dispositif s'éteint dans quelques
semaines mais surtout dans vos choix qui
ont conduit à une véritable asphyxie du
secteur et des organismes HLM supprimer
donc la RLS aux effets désastreux sur
les capacités de financement des
organismes HLM et baisser la TVA sur la
construction de logements social qui est
évidemment un bien de première nécessité
telle serait en réalité les choix qu'un
gouvernement conséquent devrait faire
mais d'ici là compte tenu de nos
observations et des conditions indignes
mais désormais coutumières d'examen de
ce texte nous nous prononcerons bien sûr
contre je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député la parole est à Madame
Emmanuelle Ménard en tant que député non
inscrite
madame la présidente Madame et messieurs
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues une fois encore une fois
de plus et une fois trop le texte dont
nous discutons aujourd'hui a été
présenté examinée et discuter à la
va-vite presque à la sauvette déposez en
urgence cette proposition de loi n'aura
donné lieu à aucune concertation aucune
étude d'impact aucune discussion franche
auprès des acteurs concernés parce que
le bouclier loyer votait l'été dernier
prendra fin le 30 juin à minuit on se
croirait dans Cendrillon il nous faut
nous prononcer en urgence sur le report
jusqu'au mois de mars prochain du
plafonnement des indices locatifs à
trois et demi pour cent aussi comme les
sénateurs je m'interroge
c'est cet hiver que nous aurions dû
travailler sur un projet de loi solide
et étayer et non aujourd'hui tout à
faits peut-être devriez-vous relire la
fontaine partir à point aller d'un train
de sénateur ce athée avec lenteur
urgence et précipitations donc qui
empêche une étude sérieuse des mesures
de plafonnement vous ne nous apportez
aucun élément d'évaluation notamment en
ce qui concerne l'impact du plafonnement
de l'indice des loyers commerciaux pas
plus que vous n'avez apporté de garantie
même verbalement au locataire sur une
hausse des aides personnelles au
logement a dû concurrence de l'indice de
référence des loyers plafonnés pas plus
que vous n'avez pris d'engagement sur la
prise en compte du besoin
d'accompagnement des propriétaires face
à ce nouvel effort très important que
vous leur demandez alors qu'ils doivent
parallèlement mettre en œuvre des
travaux de rénovation énergétique
sur le fond le plafonnement de la hausse
des indices locatifs ne peut constituer
une politique durable face à la crise du
logement que nous traversons et qui
s'aggravent alors ou presque 2 millions
et demi de Français sont en attente d'un
logement social et où 330 000 d'entre
eux sont sans domicile fixe il faudra
plus que des mesurettes pour y faire
face le loyer vous le savez est le plus
gros poste de dépenses pour les ménages
dans les zones tendues il peut
représenter jusqu'à 40% de leur budget
global cette loi en prolongeant le
plafonnement de la hausse des loyers et
donc favorable au locataire et aux
petites entreprises qui souffrent de la
crise économique et de l'inflation
malgré les dénégations du ministre de
l'économie qui se fait félicite de la
Résistance française mais gardons-nous
de croire que cette proposition de loi
ne coûtera rien l'argent n'est jamais
magique si le plafonnement souhaité par
la majorité reste un moindre mal en
comparaison du gel de loyer préconisé
par les députés de la France insoumise
la reconduction de cette mesure
représentera un effort financier de près
d'un milliard d'euros pour les bailleurs
et ce qui n'avaient pas révisé leur
loyer depuis plusieurs années seront
particulièrement pénalisés peut-être
aurait-il fallu étendre votre dispositif
aux locations saisonnières et alléger
les charges des propriétaires peut-être
faudrait-il prendre l'habitude d'inciter
plutôt que de contraindre au-delà du
texte on nous discutons l'heure est
grave alors que 82% des français
estiment que le logement devrait être
une priorité du gouvernement les
préconisations émises par le Conseil
national de la refondation ne sont pas à
la hauteur des enjeux auxquels nous
sommes confrontés là encore quelle
déception les mesures techniques
annoncées en grande pompe par le
gouvernement n'auront en effet qu'un
effet marginal quand bien même pour
reprendre les mots de la première
ministre avec beaucoup d'ambition vous
appuyez un peu sur tous les leviers
pourquoi restreindre la prorogation du
prêt à taux zéro pour les seuls
logements neufs et collectifs quand en
même temps on réforme le zan le zéro
artificiel aussi on est que dire de la
suppression du dispositif Pinel à
Béziers classés comme une B2 c'était 790
ventes en 2018 contre 197 en 2019 à la
suite de sa suppression au-delà du
logement c'est l'ensemble de l'économie
locale qui est menacée c'est rien n'est
fait l'Hérault pourrait perdre 4000
emplois dans le bâtiment d'ici fin 2024
un électrochoc est indispensable une
politique du logement digne de ce nom
est nécessaire pour répondre aux besoins
des Français qu'il souhaite devenir
propriétaire ou qu'il soit locataire
elle représenterait en outre des
recettes fiscales pour l'État en
proportion il nous faudrait faire preuve
d'ambition mais aussi d'imagination ce
n'est pas évident je le sais mais il
nous faut un véritable plan logement
avec à la clé des solutions durables et
efficaces je vous remercie merci Madame
la déboutée la discussion générale est
close monsieur le rapporteur vous
souhaitiez prendre la parole
merci madame la Présidente quelques
quelques mots en réponse à ces
interventions d'abord pour remercier les
groupes qui vont soutenir cette
proposition de loi et peut-être en
profiter pour
préciser deux trois points le premier
point monsieur Martinet depuis le début
de la discussion sur cette PPL vous
évertué avancer des contre-vérités vous
ne pouvez pas dire vous ne pouvez pas
dire que nous votons une augmentation de
7% j'ai repris votre citation c'est pour
ça en deux mois ni même en un an c'est
un plafonnement de trois plafonnement de
3 on a déjà eu le débat même et même 12
mois monsieur Martinet 7% ce n'est pas
possible c'est un plafonnement de 3 et
demi pour cent par an 3 et demi pour
cent par an donc c'est bien de se le
redire on l'a déjà eu le débat en
commission mais je vous le redis ici
vous aurez beau vous aurez beau le
présenter comme ça c'est faux ces trois
et demi par an voilà ces trois et demi
par an et je pense que c'est on l'a dit
une mesure et je voudrais rebondir sur
l'intervention de Madame Chatelain mais
qui n'est pas là c'est une PPL de
protection
arrêtez de présenter les choses vous
êtes difficiles à suivre quand même vous
êtes une mauvaise foi crasse sur ce
sujet là on intervient pour éviter une
explosion des loyers et vous arrivez à
présenter les choses en expliquant qu'on
est les méchants qui allaient augmenté
les loyers et je peux vous dire une
chose c'est que contrairement à ce qui a
été dit on a fait les auditions de tous
les acteurs concernés mais tous les
propriétaires sont pas ravis de cette
proposition de loi et Monsieur Bazin la
réévoquer tout à l'heure bien sûr qu'il
faut aussi les protéger donc si vraiment
ça n'avait aucun impact je peux vous
dire que les associations de
propriétaires n'auraient pas fait
exactement la même remarque donc c'est
bien la preuve que c'est une PPL de
protection madame Baptiste elle sur la
recherche du compromis
je vous suis et d'ailleurs merci
d'essayer de le trouver avec nous ce que
je vous dis c'est que depuis juillet
dernier cette recherche de compromis
elle a été fait notamment par les
ministres avec les acteurs concernés
pour essayer de trouver ce point
d'équipe c'est difficile à trouver le
point d'équipe quel est le bon équilibre
entre 0 et plus de 6 % en fonction de
l'évolution des charges en fonction de
l'évolution aussi des revenus par
exemple on ne l'a pas dit mais le SMIC a
augmenté depuis le 1er janvier 2022
depuis 9% donc on peut pas comparer 0 et
6% sans tenir contrôle aussi des revenus
des locataires donc on a essayé de
trouver cet équilibre il a été trouvé
l'été dernier et notre enjeu c'est ne
pas fragiliser ce dispositif juridique
ne pas prendre le risque de la censure
donc ce que je plaide depuis le début
c'est la prolongation du dispositif pour
être certain qu'il soit bien effectif et
qu'il ne tombe pas parce qu'à un moment
on aurait déséquilibré une mesure de
protection et enfin pour terminer par
rapport à l'intervention de Monsieur
Bazin je partage avec vous l'idée qu'il
faut aussi protéger les propriétaires
que certains sont confrontés à une
hausse notamment avec la rénovation
énergétique des investissements à faire
et je pense qu'on pourrait évaluer ce
dispositif dans le cas de la commission
des affaires économiques mais qu'on est
bien là dans une mesure d'urgence de
prolongation du dispositif voilà je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président de la Commission
vous souhaitez la parole merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente je voudrais madame
la Présidente de vous faire une
confidence quand le rapporteur Cazenave
est venu me parler de sa proposition de
loi fin avril il m'a présenté les choses
ainsi il m'a dit écoute Guillaume si on
fait rien si on vote rien au 1er juillet
le plafonnement de l'indice locatif que
nous avions voté à l'époque sur la loi
pouvoir d'achat va s'arrêter et les
locataires vont devoir payer plus de 6%
d'augmentation de loyer et donc moi mon
premier réflexe a été dire bah bravo de
l'avoir vu
et il a été de dire bah on va regarder
ce qu'on peut faire et le rapporteur
Cazeneuve nous a dit je propose de
prolonger ce que nous avions voté il y a
un an parce que nous sommes toujours
dans une année d'inflation pour éviter
que les loyers augmentent pour les
locataires de plus de 6%. naïvement
madame la Présidente je me suis dit
c'est une mesure aviser sociale de
protection des locataires qui va plaire
à la gauche
naïvement je me suis dit ça va faire
l'unanimité dans l'hémicycle on parle
d'une prolongation de quelques mois d'un
plafonnement de l'indice locatif
naïvement je me suis dit ça va faire
l'unanimité des deux chambres et
naïvement je me suis dit on va réussir à
faire une procédure examens simplifié et
tout le monde va se mettre d'accord pour
qu'en 5 minutes ça soit voté en
hémicycle et bien Madame la Présidente
j'ai été un peu naïf on se retrouve à la
fin des fins avec un débat complètement
absurde sur lesquels la gauche on nous
dit bah alors ça n'est pas une mesure
sociale c'est une mesure d'augmentation
des loyers c'est à dire qu'on en vient
carrément à nier le fait que si on ne
vote rien les loyers vont augmenter de
plus de 6% à partir du 1er juillet et on
en vient à faire ensuite le procès de la
politique du logement et un flashback
sur le CNR en expliquant tout ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire ce qu'on devrait
faire ce qu'il faudrait faire par la
suite et en expliquant qu'il y a mieux à
faire écouter on est avec une
proposition simplissime et je suis sûr
que les Français les locataires que ça
soit des particuliers ou que ça soit des
entreprises qui comprennent parfaitement
ce qu'on est en train de faire si on
fait rien avec ce texte passe pas c'est
plus de 6% d'Aug des loyers au 1er
juillet nous on se dit que c'est une
année un peu spéciale d'inflation et
qu'on préférait prolonger temporairement
un dispositif qui a plutôt fait ses
preuves en un an et qui vise à dire ça
sera pas plus de 3 et demi si les
propriétaires décident d'augmenter les
loyers c'est une mesure simple c'est une
mesure sociale c'est une mesure de
protection c'est une mesure temporaire
elle devrait sérieusement et
rationnellement faire l'unanimité dans
cette émission et je regrette que
certains aient décidé de faire de la
politique politicienne sur le dos des
locataires pour faire tout autre chose
que cette mesure encore une fois très
simple qui devrait faire l'unanimité sur
nos bancs merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président
j'appelle maintenant dans le texte de la
commission les articles de la
proposition de loi sur lesquels les deux
assemblées n'ont pu parvenir à un texte
identique
article premier amendement à l'article à
mon de mon pouvant être soumis une
discussion commune
amendement numéro 2
madame
Dufour est-ce que je peux vous proposer
de le présenter avec le 1
merci
donc merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur donc il s'agit
d'un moment on en a déjà parlé pour
essayer de protéger les petits commerces
et les moyens commerces de la crise et
de la case sociale absolument
terrifiante qui sont en train de vivre
je leur redonnerai juste les chiffres
vous le savez déjà 85000 emplois en
solde net détruit en disant dans le
commerce de détails non alimentaire du
fait de l'expansion du e-commerce de
votre politique ensuite là ces deux
derniers mois c'est à peu près 4000
emplois qui vont qui ont été détruits
avec les failles de Camaïeu Go-Sport
pinki etc les deux derniers mois les
deux derniers mois donc est-ce qu'on
fait maintenant on a pu discuter avec
les acteurs suite aux arguments que vous
nous aviez donné en première lecture sur
la constitutionnalité
l'inconstitutionnalité de la mesure et
écoutez ce que demande les commerces
c'est une mesure qui est provisoire elle
est forcément proportionnée et forcément
d'intérêt général puisqu'on parle de
sauver un des secteurs qui emploie le
plus de personnes en France vous mettez
2 milliards d'euros dans une usine de
batterie pour créer 1000 emplois et vous
ne pouvez pas faire un plan d'urgence
pour sauver des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois dans le secteur si dans le
secteur qui est premier secteur
employeur de France donc ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui c'est un bouger si
c'est pas le gel c'est au moins à
l'amendement suivant et aux amendements
suivants l'extension aux ETI l'accention
aux ETI du plafonnement à 3,5%. faites
quelque chose parce que vraiment encore
une fois les salariés de ce secteur ont
l'impression qu'ils sont qui sont des
salariés jetables que une travaille pas
dans les usines qui intéresse le
gouvernement que leur emploi personne
n'en a rien à faire c'est pas assez
start-up nation et je suis désolé ça
fait des années qui souffrent et
maintenant on attend des réponses mais
c'est vrai je suis désolé c'est vrai
c'est le fruit de votre politique et
vous le savez je vous remercie merci
madame la députée amendement
identique l'amendement numéro 13 madame
monsieur et janise est-ce que je peux
vous proposer de les présenter avec le
14 et le 15
merci
mais comme la très bien dit ma collègue
Marie-Noëlle baptistel on vous propose
différents étapes de compromis à la fois
le gel des loyers à 0% puis si vous ne
voulez pas 1% mais je pense qu'on peut
arriver vraiment au compromis sur le 2%
parce que ça équivaut comme ça a été dit
à la réalité de l'inflation donc si vous
voulez coller à la réalité enfin faire
une mesure de justice sociale depuis le
début de cette manature c'est le moment
d'arriver à atteindre la main aux uns
aux autres parce que je pense que
l'ensemble des parlementaires ici
peuvent se réunir sur une question de 2%
qui ne pénalisera ni les propriétaires
ni les commerçants qui sont en grande
difficulté vis-à-vis de leur loyer donc
arrivons à atterrir enfin sur quelque
chose de cohérent et qui correspondent à
la réalité parce que comme nous l'avons
dit avec vos trois et demi pour cent
nous dépassons bien largement la
question de l'inflation je vous remercie
merci Monsieur député amendement
identique
le 23 madame la Présidente châtelain
merci madame la Présidente et bien je
m'inscris dans l'ensemble des
propositions portées par mes collègues
c'est un débat que nous avons eu à
plusieurs reprises en première lecture
dans cette émission puis que nous avons
eu en commission donc voilà nous
connaissons peut-être votre votre
réponse sauf si vous avez finalement
décidé de changer d'avis nous le
redisons aujourd'hui sur des commerçants
sur des artisans c'est une part
importante de leur activité ces loyers
là aujourd'hui certains d'entre eux sont
fragilisés vous le savez la hausse de la
de l'inflation fait que certains
Français doivent réduire leurs achats
donc la question c'est d'arrêter de
toujours faire porter le poids sur les
mêmes c'est pour ça qu'on me proposons
un gel des loyers commerciaux merci
madame la Présidente donc le 14 a été
présenté avec le 13 le 15 a été présenté
avec le 13 le 9 monsieur sinieri
mes collègues Bazin malgrat c'est un
moment proposé de prolonger d'un an et
d'éteindre à tous les commerces de
toutes tailles le dispositif de
plafonnement de l'indice des loyers
commerciaux mis en place dans le cadre
de la loi portant en mesure d'urgence
pour la protection du poids d'achat il
s'agit de proposer un dispositif
identique à sur les mises en place pour
les locaux d'habitation qui concerne
tous les locataires et tous les
bailleurs quel que soit leur situation
juridique la loi pour le pouvoir d'achat
adopté à l'été 2022 a mis en place un
plafonnement de l'ILC à un niveau de
3,5% mais avait limité son application
TPE et PME le législateur le
gouvernement n'avait alors pas souhaité
éteindre le dispositif de plafonnement à
l'ensemble des entreprises laissant
notamment les réseaux d'enseignants
d'enseigne pardon tenter d'obtenir des
accords de gré à gré avec l'Empire merci
merci monsieur le député l'amendement
numéro 33 madame Ménard
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement de précision parce que donc
vous proposez de poursuivre le mécanisme
qui a été voté l'été dernier et donc de
plafonner les loyers à 3,5 % pour
effectivement compenser les effets de
l'inflation et moi je vous propose quand
même de préciser et c'est l'objet de mon
amendement que ce mécanisme sera
effectivement instauré et perpétuer à
condition en fait que le taux
d'inflation annuelle reste supérieure à
5% par an parce que imaginez que d'un
coup l'inflation baisse je le souhaite
d'ailleurs que l'inflation baisse de
façon significative et on va avoir un
mécanisme de de contrôle les loyers qui
va continuer à s'imposer alors qu'on
pourrait tout à fait le supprimer plus
rapidement donc c'est un amendement de
précision voilà il faut que le taux
d'inflation annuel reste supérieur à 5%
pour que ce contrôle des loyers puisse
continuer à s'imposer je vous remercie
merci merci madame la députée amendement
identique
l'amendement numéro 20 ne me semble pas
défendu
l'amendement numéro 22 ne me semble pas
défendu l'amendement numéro 10 monsieur
Bazin ce que je peux vous proposer une
présentation commune avec le numéro 11
bien sûr pour vous êtes agréable
président merci beaucoup monsieur Bazin
pour éclairer la représentation on est
du même département c'est pour ça pour
éclairer leur présentation nationale ils
sont en discussion commune mais ils sont
pas du tout dans le même esprit que les
amendements qui viennent défendus de
l'autre côté de l'hémicycle puisque moi
je veux poser à travers ces deux
amendements d'appel
la question du montant on reproduit
trois et demi est-ce que trois et demi
et le bon montant au regard des
prévisions l'été dernier nous avions eu
le même sujet je regarde le président de
la commission des affaires économiques
quand nous discutions sur la Web pouvoir
d'achat on se disait d'ailleurs oui on
ne prévoit pour une année mais en
réalité au bout de six mois ça devrait
redescendre assez rapidement la réalité
a montré que ça n'a pas été le cas
malheureusement pour les Français et
donc là on se dit ça va descendre aussi
assez rapidement d'ailleurs le
rapporteur un moment à mentionner d'ici
quelques mois je l'espère mais on n'est
pas force il y a un pari qui est fait à
travers ce montant et donc l'équilibre
qui est recherché il est aussi quand
même sujet à ce Paris donc moi je posais
la question mais c'était un peu pour
contrebalancer les les choix négatifs de
l'autre côté moi je proposais 4 mais
finalement 3 et demi c'est peut-être
mieux le deuxième amendement est un peu
différent mais il vient poser les
différentes questions qui se posent pour
les propriétaires ils ont parfois
emprunté le coup du crédit augmente je
pense qu'on aime la ministre qu'on va
t'engenteer 4% on était à 1% en taux
d'intérêt sur la question de
l'approvisionnement des matériaux on a
enregistré une hausse de 27% un an sur
la question de la taxe foncière on a
voté enfin on n'a pas voté parce qu'il y
avait eu des 49-3 mais les bases ont
augmenté de 7,1%. on voit bien pour les
propriétaires un certain nombre de
postes ont augmenté et donc la question
c'est est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas un autre
dispositif qu'un montant fixe ce serait
plutôt un plafond glissant qui
reprendrait un système inspiré des
années 90 ou finalement on prendrait la
moyenne de l'IRL des 4 derniers
trimestres donc c'est une proposition au
débat c'est encore un amendement d'appel
parce que l'idée de pouvoir aller assez
vite
merci monsieur le député avant de
prendre vos avis je vous informe que sur
les votes de l'amendement 3 des
amendements 19 et identiques et sur
l'article premier je suis saisi par le
groupe renaissance d'une demande de
scrutin public les scrutins sont
annoncés dans la dans l'ensemble de
l'Assemblée nationale pardon monsieur le
rapporteur vos avis sur les amendements
de cette discussion commune s'il vous
plaît
merci madame la Présidente
s'agissant des amendements de de gel des
loyers
vous évoquez notamment la situation des
commerçants je peux vous dire que dans
toutes les auditions que nous avons fait
puis faire et les déplacements toutes
les fédérations en charge des commerces
soutiennent cette proposition de loi et
soutiennent le plafonnement à 3,5 parce
que ils ont bien conscience que c'est
une solution d'équilibre et je peux vous
dire je n'ai pas vu d'acteurs du
commerce me demander d'aller plus loin
et d'aller jusqu'au gel pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont bien conscience qu'on doit
trouver cette position d'équilibre et
qu'en face on a des propriétaires qui
ont aussi des charges qui sont aussi
touchées par l'inflation et également
j'y reviendrai sans cesse parce que
c'est notre responsabilité de garantir
le système évitez la censure par un
dispositif déséquilibré
s'agissant également de votre
proposition d'élargir aux ETI
et c'est également le cas de Monsieur
signéry sur l'extension aux ETI et à
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur taille
les entreprises les plus touchées ce
sont les PME les TPE et les artisans
pourquoi parce que elles ne peuvent pas
je vous réponds madame Dufour parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas négocier avec
leur bailleur elles ne peuvent pas
négocier avec leur bailleur donc on
protège les entreprises qui n'ont pas de
rapport de négociation avec leur
bailleur les ETI je rappelle que ça peut
être des entreprises qui vont jusqu'à
1,5 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires ça peut être des filiales de
grands groupes internationaux je ne nie
pas qu'il n'y ait pas des difficultés
dans ce secteur là en revanche ce n'est
pas celle qui sont un les plus touchées
et deux une nouvelle fois à trop élargir
le dispositif on ouvre un risque un
risque de le faire tomber par par la
censure constitutionnelle et c'est
exactement pour les mêmes raisons
monsieur signéry qui ne me sont pas
opportuns d'ouvrir à toutes les
entreprises y compris les plus rentables
de France qui n'ont aucun problème à
payer leur loyer le dispositif de
plafonnement restons dans dans l'esprit
d'une mesure de ciblage pour celles et
ceux qui sont le plus en difficulté et
je pense que les PME les TPE les
artisans sont le cœur de cible de cette
proposition de loi
madame Ménard je partage
votre objectif de trouver un système
plus pérenne d'une certaine manière
à travers une forme de tunnel derrière
l'inflation la difficulté que l'on
rencontre c'est que nous sommes obligés
de le borner dans le temps ce dispositif
pourquoi parce qu'on vient toucher là je
l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure sur la
liberté contractuelle aux droits de
propriété et le juge constitutionnel
attend de nous que nous n'en serions y
compris dans le temps y compris dans le
temps or votre amendement vise à le
pérenniser et donc plus d'échéance
temporelles et de mon point de vue ça
nous ouvre un risque là encore un risque
de disproportion et donc de censure
quant à Monsieur Bazin
si vous déposez un amendement à 4 on
n'est pas très loin de 3,5 quand
viendrait je pense qu'on est quand même
pas très loin de trouver un accord sur
cette proposition de proposition de loi
et pourquoi encore une fois plutôt trois
et demi que 4 je ne fais que proposer le
rappeler président kasbien prolongé à
dispositif que nous avons déjà voté ni
plus ni moins et par rapport à
proposition en amendement qui qui ne
fait pas référence à l'ILC mais l'IRL
vous savez que si on adoptait votre
amendement ça ferait tomber le
plafonnement de de l'IMC donc pour
toutes ces raisons j'ai mis un avis
défavorable à cette série d'amendements
merci
merci donc défavorable sur tous les
amendements merci attendez je comprends
vous devez une suspension
pardon
d'accord donc je l'avais pas noté à vous
madame la ministre excusez-moi
si madame la Présidente
pardonnez-moi je en écoutant la liste
des amendements
je me demandais si
il valait mieux partager avec vous que
le mieux est l'ennemi du bien ou qu'un
tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
au choix
non mais voilà j'ai pas envie d'être
superfétatoire je trouve que c'est un
mot
alors je vais essayer de poursuivre ma
pensée malgré les interventions de
Madame Simonet dans le respect
républicain on va le dire simplement
mon souhait il est clair c'était le même
en première lecture protéger les TPE les
PME de la hausse des loyers je le
redirai aussi simplement si on change un
des trois paramètres que vient de citer
le rapporteur
si on change l'intensité si on change le
périmètre si on change la durée on prend
tout simplement un risque qui est de
voir cette proposition de loi de
protection sur les loyers commerciaux
être retoqué au Conseil constitutionnel
le rapporteur cazena vient de le dire on
touche aux droits de
ça on touche au droite propriété c'est
un droit qui est encadré peu importe ce
qu'on pense certains
si éventuellement on pouvait parler ce
serait bien
s'il vous plaît seul la ministre à la
parole
la ministre elle a une voix qui est en
train de se casser et comme elle a à
cœur d'aller au bout de son argumentaire
elle garde ce qui lui reste je reviens
donc sur ce que je vous ai dit on prend
un risque qui est très clair à force de
vouloir plus à force de vouloir toucher
à l'intensité à force de vouloir
peut-être comme le député signaleri la
mentionné le député basin élargir aux
etes que je comprends très bien non mais
ce sont des propositions de vos banques
qui sont intéressantes on prend un
risque c'est que tous les 10 fils de
cette proposition s'effondre on prend un
risque c'est qu'au mois de septembre ce
mois de septembre les loyers commerciaux
de nos petits commerçants augmentent et
qu'il ne soit pas protégé le risque ne
vaut pas le risque n'en vaut pas la
chandelles et donc pour les raisons
suivantes parce que il faut rester
proportionné en intensité
je rejetterai les amendements et
j'aurais un avis défavorable sur les
amendements de gel je tiens quand même à
apporter une précision à la
représentation nationale c'est que ça
n'est pas une histoire uniquement madame
baptistel de pommes même si on aime les
pommes coupées en deux c'est quelques
semaines de pommes ou de poire coupée en
deux sur les 6% 0% 3 et demi c'est le
fruit d'une concertation et j'ai à cœur
de vous dire avec qui avec la
Confédération des commerçants de France
avec les commerçants et les artisans des
métropoles de France avec la
confédération générale de l'alimentation
de détails avec l'u2p que vous
connaissez bien les indépendants mais
aussi le conseil du commerce de France
cette position elle est partagée par
l'ensemble des organismes que je viens
de vous citer qui sont représentatifs
des petits commerçants de grâce ne
touchons ni à l'intensité ni à la durée
ni au périmètre le cas échéant c'est
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi qui
sera retoquée et les loyers augmentaient
c'est pourquoi j'aurais un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble de ces
amendes donc je vous remercie
merci Madame la ministreuse j'ai deux
demandes de prise de parole monsieur
Bricout
merci de la présidente pour écouter moi
je soutiendrai tous les amendements qui
visent à limiter en fin de compte la
hausse des loyers pour pour les petits
commerces alors j'ai bien entendu
monsieur le ministre vous avez essayé de
la ministre aussi de de trouver des
équilibres entre les propriétaires les
locataires
mais enfin moi je crois que ça me paraît
très difficile quand même pour les
petits commerces la situation ça a été
dit depuis la crise covid l'e-commerce
continue de grimper etc ils sont quand
même dans une concurrence effrénée et
des charges qui continuent d'augmenter
et moi je crois que en fin de compte si
vous si vous protégez pas mieux en fin
de compte le petit commerce on va aller
voir fermer les uns après les autres
tout simplement et les propriétaires
mais ils auront plus locataires tout
simplement c'est pas mieux pour eux et
vous l'avez dit c'est souvent des
propriétaires des petits propriétaires
des propriétaires qui attendent
justement après ces loyers pour pour
payer pour avoir leur retraite donc on
voit bien que si ça se passait mal pour
le pour leur locataire ça se passe mal
aussi pour eux et puis je crois que
c'est souvent aussi des des anciens
commerçants qui ont cédé leur bail ils
sont parfaitement capables de comprendre
la situation et d'accepter tout
simplement merci monsieur le député
monsieur Bazin
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de commission sur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues vous avez
à mon avis madame la ministre fait une
erreur concernant ce que je portais
parce que moi j'ai jamais porté
l'élargissement des ETI ben oui mais je
pense que c'est important pour la clarté
il y a des nuances dans cette émission
sur les positions et je crois que les ça
fait partie de la déclarer
l'augmentation nationale mais deux
amendements étaient des amendements
d'appel qui ne savent qui ne se
positionne pas exactement dans la même
dynamique que les amendements notamment
de la nups donc moi je vais les retirer
soucieux qu'on trouve rapidement
des solutions pour autant monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez dit il est urgent
de prolonger
dès le départ on a dit oui mais il est
en même temps urgent d'accompagner vous
avez mentionné tout à l'heure que vous
étiez prêt avec le président de la
Commission à faire un travail sur
l'évaluation
il n'y a pas que des données économiques
il y a aussi des données fiscales et
aujourd'hui un certain nombre d'éléments
sur la table on le sait bien aujourd'hui
et c'est pour ça qu'on s'opposera aux
amendements qui sont proposés sur le
blocage total des loyers c'est que ce
serait un message qui désinciterait à
l'investissement immobilier qui
désinciterait à la rénovation alors
qu'on a cruellement besoin que les
Français réinvestissent leur logement
bailleurs publics comme privé
rénove et améliore les logements qui
sont mises à disposition et surtout qui
ne
qui continuent à mettre à la location
leur bien parce que on a plusieurs
centaines de milliers de logements qui
ont été sortis de la location et qui
manque cruellement aux Français on a des
besoins importants et il est important
aujourd'hui d'apporter une solution en
plus et même la ministre monsieur le
ministre nous ont nous vous attendons
sur des mesures fortes pour accompagner
et relancer le logement en France les ce
qui a été annoncé ce CNR est insuffisant
vous le comprenez bien et la
représentation nationale est extrêmement
frustrée de pas pouvoir en débattre dès
à présent merci monsieur le député donc
les amendements 10 et 11 sont retirés
nous passons au vote
donc c'est scrutins sont à main levés
chers collègues ce sont les amendements
d'après qui sont parce que un public
je me vois l'amendement numéro 2 qui a
reçu un double avis défavorable
commission gouvernement qui épouse
qui est contre ils sont rejetés
amendement numéro 1 même avis même vote
amendement très identique même à vivre
même vote 14 MAM a vu même vote 15 ma
vie même vote 9 même avis même vote
je me vois la maman numéro 9 double avis
des favorable qui est pour
qui compte rejeté un moment 33 même ma
vie même vote
amendement numéro 3
madame Dufour
là là c'est pas non mais pour rebondir
sur la question des et je vais répondre
aux rapporteur je vais être très brève
oui on échange avec les représentants
des commerçants on les connaît très bien
on échange aussi avec les représentants
des ETI vous ne répondez jamais quand je
vous dis qu'il y a des et qui font
faillite en ce moment même et qu'on a
4000 emplois on a perdu 4000 emplois
dans des ETI qui vendent de
l'habillement en France aucune réponse
zéro comme d'habitude sur le pouvoir de
négociation vous baser sur quelle étude
d'impact quelle étude d'impact pour
affirmer que les ETI sont en capacité de
redonner gaucher leur loyer commerciaux
avec leur bailleur c'est pas parce
qu'elles ont un gros chiffre d'affaires
qu'elles sont en capacité d'être dans un
rapport de force favorable avec oui et
gros chiffre d'affaires ça veut pas dire
ça veut pas dire être en bonne santé
financière j'ai pas pour lui apprendre
madame Olivier Olivia Grégoire
franchement vous confondez chiffre
d'affaires et bénéfice maintenant
sérieusement non mais honnêtement
honnêtement honnêtement quelles études
d'impact vous avez pour affirmer qu'ils
sont en capacité aujourd'hui de faire
baisser de même leur commerciaux dans
cette crise vous n'apportez encore une
fois aucune réponse et c'est les
entreprises en question qui nous le
disent donc arrêtez de nous faire croire
que il y a que vous qui les échangez
avec eux c'est complètement faux déjà
premièrement donc ça c'est le premier
point et le deuxième point je voudrais
quand même souligner ce qui vient de se
passer les macronistes et le RN votre
contre le gel des loyers pour les petits
commerçants vous dites que vous les
aimez à longueur de journée vous citiez
des proverbes mais avec des amis comme
vous on n'a pas besoin d'ennemis très
sérieusement
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
c'est quand même incroyable vous êtes
prêts à nous faire courir un risque pour
toutes les PME les TPE et les artisans
en défendant les ETI c'est ça le risque
que nous fait de courir en élargissant
le dispositif vous découvrons désormais
une passion pour les ETI dans ce pays
parce que c'est quand même nouveau il
faut bien se le dire vous courrez le
risque de fragiliser les plus petits
ceux qui sont les plus en difficulté et
par ailleurs mais je pense que c'est un
sujet rédactionnel votre amendement il
est rétroactif il conduit à revoir les
loyers qui ont été pratiqués en courant
2022 donc il faudrait retourner vers les
propriétaires et leur redemander
appliquer rétroactivement les loyers et
leur demander un surplus de loyer qui a
été pratiqué donc là je peux vous dire
que le risque constitutionnel il est au
carré et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai mis un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre
c'est pas parce qu'on refuse de prendre
un risque constitutionnel sur les ETI
qu'on est pas sensible si la réponse
vous intéresse madame la députée Dufour
à la situation des ETI notamment dans le
secteur de l'habillement
pendant que certains parlent discutent
perror sur ses bancs toutes les semaines
je suis avec les commerçants donc les
considérations sur les commerçants de
France je crois pouvoir dire que je les
connais je les porte et je me bats pour
eux faire prendre le risque aujourd'hui
faire prendre le risque aujourd'hui que
000 commerçants de proximité voient leur
loyer exploser sous prétexte qu'on a
écrit un amendement pour élargir aux ETI
qui fait retoquer par le Conseil
constitutionnel prenez vos
responsabilités je prends les miennes
c'est un avis défavorable je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais mettre voile amendement
numéro 3 qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin éclos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votants 156 exprimés 146 majorités 74
pour 53 contre 93 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté amendement
identique l'amendement numéro 19 madame
Valentin
n'est pas là l'amendement numéro 21
n'est pas défendu
nous en venons au scrutin à l'article
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je me vois l'article premier
je vous prie de bien vouloir regagner
vos places le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 161
exprimés 160 majorité 81 pour 126 contre
34 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
nous en venons à l'article de inscrit
sur l'article 2 monsieur signéry
merci madame la Présidente oui l'article
de maintien le plafonnement de l'indice
de référence des loyers au bénéfice des
ménages jusqu'au premier trimestre de
l'année 2024 j'espère chers collègues
que nous n'aurons pas à proroger une
nouvelle fois se dispositif d'ici là si
nous sommes ici ce soir c'est parce que
le Sénat a voulu sanctionner
l'impréparation du gouvernement et de la
majorité Karine le s'agit pas vraiment
d'une initiative parlementaire mais
plutôt d'une manœuvre de ne pas avoir à
produire une étude d'impact toutefois
par responsabilité de nos opposerons pas
non plus à cet article 2 regarde
l'urgence pour protéger nos concitoyens
qui risquent de voir leur loyer exploser
en juillet même si cette proposition de
loi n'empêchera pas de possible
contournement comme la hausse du loyer
par un propriétaire avant l'arrivée d'un
nouveau locataire il aurait mieux valu
que la revalorisation des loyers soit
plutôt effectuer sur la moyenne de l'IRL
des quatre derniers trimestres ce qui
permettrait une plus juste prise en
compte de l'inflation tout en préservant
une mesure équilibrée et une répartition
de l'effort entre bailleur et locataire
merci merci monsieur le député avant de
donner l'apport la parole au prochain
orateur je vous informe que sur le vote
de la maman 16 et l'amendement 18 je
suis saisie par le groupe socialiste et
apparenté d'une demande de scrutin
public sur le vote de l'article 2 et sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de l'Oise
je suis saisie par le groupe renaissance
d'une demande de scrutin public les
scrutins sont annoncés dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale Monsieur
Philippe liotto loto pardon pour le
groupe rassemblement national
monsieur Miss monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues nous trouvons
aujourd'hui devant un éclatant exemple
de l'imprévoyance qui caractéristique si
bien ce gouvernement au dernier moment
nous avons cette proposition de loi qui
reconduit donc les mesures de
plafonnement des loyers prévus dans la
loi pouvoir d'achat nous voterons pour
cet article 2 n'y voyez cependant pas
une adhésion à votre politique qui est
tente de combler des failles avec des
rustines un peu compliqué mais plutôt
notre soutien au pouvoir d'achat des
Français qui souffrent de l'inflation et
ont chaque mois de plus en plus de mal à
payer leur facture car cette mesure
d'équilibre qui limite l'augmentation
pour les foyers français et cependant
bien insuffisant pour faire face aux
problèmes des locataires car elles ne
s'accompte pas d'une véritable politique
dans la durée aujourd'hui la
construction est en berne notamment car
nombre de ménages doivent reporter leur
projet d'achat de fait le secteur
locatif privé comme social perd en
fluidité avec donc une pression accrue
sur les prix particulièrement aux zones
tendues cette pression va encore
s'accroître dans l'avenir avec la mise
en place brutale du diagnostic de
performance énergétique qui va sortir
des dizaines de milliers de logements du
marché de la location et au lieu
d'encourager la prise de la construction
vous venez avec l'annonce de la
suppression du Pinel et la réduction du
périmètre du PTZ renforcer les
difficultés pour des économies qui
seront réduites et qui vont d'une part
créer un très formant qui a gagné pour
l'État en TVA et d'autre part précipités
une crise sociale et économique alors
oui à cette mesure mais qui ne serait
marqué l'absence de politique pour
favoriser l'accession notamment sociale
à la propriété l'investissement locatif
et la fluidité comme le renforcement du
parc social je vous remercie merci merci
monsieur le député Monsieur William
Martinez
merci madame la Présidente je vais
insister sur un seul point je suis
frappé du décalage qu'il existe entre
cette émission où la minorité
présidentielle nous dit plus 3,5 %,
c'est une mesure de compromis c'est une
mesure raisonnable il faut la voter
sinon ce sera le chaos le décalage entre
ces propos et la réalité sociale et la
réalité sociale c'est qu'il y a 26
millions de locataires dans notre pays
dont une grande partie d'entre eux je
vous le dis ils sont pris à la gorge il
n'en peuvent plus parce que les loyers
sont extrêmement élevés vous savez
depuis les années 60 il y a eu un
bouleversement dans le budget des
ménages le logement est passé devant
l'alimentation c'est à dire que
maintenant le premier poste de dépenses
ça fait 28% du revenu en moyenne c'est
le logement mais quand on dit 28% en
moyenne quand on parle des cœurs des
métropoles là où le prix est le plus
élevé quand on parle des classes
populaires des classes moyennes on est
bien au-delà de 28% on est à des taux
d'efforts qui font 40 50 % voilà il y a
des gens qui n'en peuvent plus à cause
du prix des loyers et comment plus ces
derniers temps c'est rajouter
l'explosion des charges et chers
collègues vous l'avez peut-être vu dans
vos circonscriptions j'ose espérer qu'il
y a des locataires qui vont frapper à la
porte de vos permanences parlementaires
pour vous dire les charges locatives
c'est plus 50 + 100 + 150 euros par mois
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer
dans le pays alors Monsieur le Ministre
du Logement parle souvent avec une
expression très juste de la bombe
sociale qui est le logement mais ça y
est la bombe sociale elle a explosé
voilà il y a des gens qui prennent des
prêts à la consommation pour pouvoir
payer leurs charges qui renonce à payer
les études de leurs enfants qui parfois
renoncent à juste leur acheter des
vêtements neufs parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens à cause des prix des loyers
alors chers collègues moi je veux bien
qu'on est une forme qui soit tout à fait
polissée qu'on dise qu'il faut trouver
des compromis mais je vous demande juste
de réaliser à quel point sur le terrain
dans la vie des gens la solution est
absolument catastrophique et ce plus
trois et demi pour cent que vous voulez
faire voter avec cette article 2 ce sera
catastrophique nous en venons aux
amendements à l'article
amendement pouvant être soumis une
discussion comme une amendement numéro
16 madame batistel
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur donc
je crois avoir fait la démonstration
dans mon intervention
en discussion générale de ce que nous
vous proposons sur ces trois amendements
madame la Présidente si vous acceptez je
peux défendre les trois à la fois le
premier étant donc vous proposez avec
cet article 2 de reconduire le mécanisme
adopté dans la loi porte en mesure
d'urgence pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat ce qui est heureux
sauf que la progression des loyers sur
deux ans n'en est pas moins fulgurantes
puisqu'elle atteindra
7,2% donc une telle évolution est
évidemment en décalage avec l'évolution
des salaires et des pensions sur la même
période qui est évidemment très
inférieure et avec l'augmentation des
charges que chacun reconnaît ici qui
sont sans précédent donc cet amendement
a pour objet de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des locataires et donc de
demander un gel des loyers donc on se
contenterait de cette augmentation de
3,5% qui avait été prévu l'année
dernière et qui finalement perdurera
évidemment sur cette année et il n'y
aurait pas d'augmentation supplémentaire
je rappelle que si nous votons votre
proposition et qu'on fait le calcul sur
un loyer moyen en France qui est de 723
euros on se retrouve avec une
augmentation de 617 euros qui correspond
à un mois de loyer supplémentaire et
c'est évidemment pas acceptable sur le
cumul avec l'augmentation des charges
dans un souci de compromis nous vous
proposons avec l'amendement 17 de avoir
une un mécanisme qui bloque la
progression à 1% et surtout sur
l'amendement 18 et je crois que celle là
elle est vraiment acceptable puisque
c'est une proposition de plafonnement à
2% et lorsque Monsieur le rapporteur
vous dites que vous craignez que ce soit
anticonstitutionnel je pense que ni les
sages ni les Français ne trouverez ça
indécent que nous bloquions les loyers à
un taux qui est finalement celui de
l'inflation et selon les statistiques de
l'INSEE donc franchement je crois qu'il
y a très peu de risques voire pas de
risque du tout que cela soit
anticonstitutionnel et nous vous
demandons donc une dernière fois de
d'avoir une mesure sociale et de donner
un avis favorable à cet moment de
compromis merci madame la députée
amendement numéro 24
merci madame la Présidente je serai
peut-être un peu plus dur que ma
collègue
en fait je ne me félicite pas que vous
ne fassiez rien vous avez raison si vous
ne faisez rien la situation serait pire
mais à faire on peut pas se concentrer
du minimum et je vais quand même vous
expliquer pourquoi vous nous dites le
plus 3,5 au final c'est pour répartir
50% pour les locataires 50% pour les
propriétaires on passe le fait que ce
bien il appartient bien au propriétaire
et que c'est eux infini qui en auront
soit la jouissante soit qui en auront
les gains quand ils revendront mais même
si on met ça de côté aujourd'hui si on
prend l'ensemble des Français qu'ils
soient locataire ou qu'ils soient
propriétaire et si on regarde qui sur
qui pèse le plus dans leur dépense
totale les loyers c'est les locataires
et c'est notamment les locataires les
plus modestes les français pour qui le
loyer est une dépense la plus forte et
la plus contrainte ce sont les Français
les plus modestes pour qui ça représente
entre 45 et 32% de leur budget c'est
énorme et c'est d'énormes puisque pour
les 10% les plus riches c'est seulement
10% de leurs revenus qui est consacré
aujourd'hui à leur logement et leurs
dépenses d'habitation donc c'est une
dépense qui va de 10% la différence
c'est 10% donc il vous avez 90 % de
votre revenu pour faire ce que vous
voulez et dans l'autre des cas c'est
quasiment jusqu'à 50 % de vos revenus
c'est contre ça qu'on se voit c'est à
dire que c'est des gens qui
effectivement on le couteau sous la gare
et il se trouve beaucoup plus chez les
locataires et enfin quand même pour pour
reprendre sur cette question là c'est
que ça a été dit en 1977 on visait à
limiter le taux d'effort à 17%.
aujourd'hui les propositions du CNR vous
proposent de les limiter à 25% nous
sommes largement dessus et si vous
augmentez de plus 3,5%, ça veut dire que
la part des loyers dans le revenu va
encore augmenter parce que les les
revenus n'augmentent pas de
3,5%. alors je crois que monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
a peur d'être convaincu que ce qui
m'écoute assez peu je vous le redis
aujourd'hui si vous augmentez de 3,5%,
les revenus n'augmentent pas à ce niveau
là c'est à dire que le poids des pour
les ménages le poids du logement va
augmenter merci madame la Présidente
l'amendement numéro 17 a été défendu
avec le 16 tout comme le 18
l'amendement numéro 28 monsieur peut
oui merci madame la Présidente j'ai pas
fait de rappel au règlement tout à
l'heure mais je vous signale quand même
que avant de partir je m'étais accordé
avec Madame Ménard pour permuter ça a
été signalé à la présence vous en avez
pas tenu compte ce qui fait que je suis
arrivé en retard c'est pas c'est pas
correct du point de vue des usages dans
notre émission mais bon je passe je
passe
j'en viens à j'en viens à mon amendement
moi ce que je voudrais dire en
complément de ce qu'on vient de dire mes
collègues
c'est que
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est le chèque
qu'un locataire fait à la fin du mois et
le chèque que le locataire fait à la fin
du mois ce n'est pas le loyer le chèque
que le locataire fait à la fin du mois
ça s'appelle la quittance et dans la
quittance il y a le loyer et il y a les
charges or les charges ont augmenté de
manière extrêmement forte notamment en
raison du prix de l'énergie donc les
circonstances dans lesquelles on étudie
cette proposition sans étude d'impact
sans évaluation nous permet pas de
mesurer qu'elle a été l'augmentation de
la quittance mais si on en croit les
bailleurs publics comme les bailleurs
privés et si on se renseigne un peu on a
une quittance de loyer qui a augmenté
loyers plus charges environ entre 10 et
13% en moyenne l'an dernier si on vous
suit sur cette proposition ça veut dire
que ça va être bis répétita entre 10 et
13%, peut-être plus pour
peut-être plus pour ceux qui sont
chauffés au gaz puisque le bouclier
tarifaire va prendre fin au premier
juillet c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous proposons une mesure de protection
du pouvoir d'achat des 40 % de
locataires qui représentent pour
l'essentiel les 40 % des Français les
plus modestes qu'ils soient jeunes
salariés ou retraités et d'avoir un gel
des loyers éventuellement compenser de
façon à avoir une mesure protectrice
réellement protectrice merci monsieur le
député pour la bonne information de tout
le monde et je pense que du coup ça
pourra servir à tout le monde les
chances n'est pas possible n'est
possible qu'entre rateur de groupe votre
groupe a été informé et donc les choses
n'est pas possible avec un orateur
nonasque
avec un orateur non inscrit j'ai eu en
plus dans la prévenu votre groupe que
les changes n'étaient pas possible et
j'ai eu en plus la gentillesse quand un
huissier m'a fait signe que un orateur
de votre groupe arrivé en courant de
patienter quelques secondes pour que une
personne de votre groupe puisse prendre
la parole je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur vos avis sur ses amendements
oui merci madame la Présidente de trois
éléments d'abord
tous les tous les propriétaires ne sont
pas des grandes foncières
c'est aussi un revenu complémentaire un
loyer je vois également les bailleurs
sociaux j'ai pas entendu les
représentants des bailleurs sociaux
demandés un gel des loyers donc je pense
que sur ce sujet là il nous faut désolé
de le répéter une position d'équilibre
d'autre part ils font face à des charges
en leur demande de rénover leur logement
ils font face à la hausse de la taxe
foncière donc eux aussi ils sont sujets
à l'inflation et oui madame Battistel
c'est une mesure sociale
je le redis c'est une mesure de
protection si nous ne faisons rien nous
laissons seul face à l'augmentation des
loyers donc c'est bien une mesure
sociale et
on peut toujours faire plus mais dans ce
cadre là c'est pas possible pour les
raisons que je vous ai évoqué c'est à
dire et d'équilibre et de sécurité
juridique et d'autre part
je voudrais quand même redire parce
qu'on a l'impression que cette mesure
c'est pas la seule qui vient protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français quand on a
revalorisé de 4% les aides l'été dernier
que le SMIC a augmenté de plus de 9%
depuis janvier depuis janvier 22 que le
bouclier que le bouclier tarifaire pour
répondre à Monsieur peu limite
l'augmentation des charges donc pour
toutes ces raisons là pour toutes ces
raisons là j'ai même un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je voudrais redire
un certain nombre de choses d'abord pour
les questions du retard de préparation
du gouvernement je vous rappelle que ces
mesures sont nécessaires d'être prises
avant le premier octobre donc on est le
19 juin ou le 20 juin je ne sais plus
mais on est très loin du premier octobre
et donc nous sommes donc à temps et je
le redis ça a été dit plusieurs fois
nous ne pouvons pas faire ces
propositions tant que nous avions pas
une vision suffisante du niveau de
l'inflation pour ne pas être dans
l'illégalité et comme vous le dites dans
la préparation ensuite pour ce qui est
des amendements proposés je le redis
comme ça a été dit par monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes bien là dans une
protection équilibrée des locataires
avec une un plafonnement à 3,5 pour une
année supplémentaire et bien trois et
demi par an comme ça a été rappelé
préalablement mesure qui a été utilisé
ça déjà été dit cette fois-ci on ne
parle que du du logement privé puisque
une mesure supplémentaire de
plafonnement pour le logement social
devra être prise après juin 2024 si elle
était nécessaire mais force est de
constater que les bailleurs sociaux ont
été souvent pas tous fort heureusement à
utiliser le plafonnement tel qu'il a été
proposé et si nous n'avions pas fait
cette mesure de plafonnement un certain
nombre de bailleurs sociaux aurait très
probablement été au-delà de notre
plafonnement contenu de la situation des
bailleurs donc notre proposition elle
est juste elle est équilibrée elle
permettra au locataire de de logement
privé d'avoir une hausse modérée une
nouvelle fois en 2024 et tout autre à la
fois dans le territoire hexagonal de
trois et demi deux et demi en outre-mer
et 2% en Corse et donc quel que soit les
amendements celui du gel bien sûr qui
est parfaitement inconstitutionnel et
vous le savez même si vous dites le
contraire et puis les mesures
intermédiaires et bien nous émettons un
avis défavorable je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur Royer
Pérou
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure un
de nos collègues expliquer que
apparemment seul la gauche comprendrait
en quelque sorte ce qu'est la réalité
sociale je voudrais je voudrais quand
même vous préciser cher collègue que il
y a ici sur ces bancs des collègues qui
ont été maire qui ont même été président
d'office HLM et le président d'office
HLM que j'ai été pendant quasiment 10
ans et bien figurez-vous qu'il fait
partie de ceux qui effectivement ont
assumé pendant 7 ans 7 ans le gel des
loyers pourquoi j'ai pu le faire j'ai pu
le faire parce que j'avais une structure
financière saine parce que ça m'a permis
malgré le fait d'avoir donc le gel des
loyers de pouvoir continuer à investir
de pouvoir continuer à produire du
logement social et à partir du moment où
vous avez une gestion saine de votre
fils HLM ou de votre ESH à ce moment-là
vous pouvez vous permettre ce genre de
choses mais la réalité et vous le savez
tous très bien c'est que nous devons
produire du logement nous devons
entretenir nos logements nous devons
faire de la rénovation énergétique et
tout ça vous le financez comment pas
simplement par des subventions vous le
financez aussi par les loyers et donc à
un moment donné mes chers collègues le
logement social c'est la finalité du
logement qui est social mais le logement
social reste une opération économique et
donc aujourd'hui je considère que les
efforts qui sont demandés certes qui
visent à contenir contenir
l'augmentation des loyers c'est quelque
chose de sain et qui répond me
semble-t-il à la situation économique
que nous connaissons sans oublier quand
même mes chers collègues une grande
partie des locataires dans le logement
social sont à paysés et donc une grande
partie d'entre eux ne sont pas concernés
par l'augmentation des loyers et donc
quand vous faites votre démonstration il
faut tout dire et ne pas avoir
simplement la version sélective des
choses
merci monsieur le député monsieur
martinet
[Applaudissements]
merci collègue d'avoir ouvert ce débat
je me permets de rebondir immédiatement
dessus l'exemple que vous nous donnez
est très intéressant vous nous dites
j'ai pu geler les loyers à la tête de
mon office HLM parce que sa situation
économique était saine mais chers
collègues qu'est-ce qui depuis 2017 a
mis en difficulté les bailleurs a mis à
plat leur situation économique vous le
savez très bien si si vous connaissez le
secteur vous le savez c'est la mesure de
la RLS et l'augmentation de la TVA les
deux mesures qui ont été prises par la
majorité macroniste en 2017 et qui a mis
à plat le modèle économique des
bailleurs qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont toutes les difficultés du monde que
ce soit à produire du logement ou à
résister à la tentation d'augmenter les
loyers comme le permet une hausse de
l'IRL donc merci de cette démonstration
collègue Avran c'est vrai c'était
possible de geler les loyers sur
l'initiative du bailleur mais avec votre
politique depuis 2017 parce que vous
avez tout cassé ce n'est plus possible
nous nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je devais donc mettre au voile
amendement numéro 16 qui a reçu un
double avis défavorable je vous prie de
bien vouloir regagner vos places le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 168 exprimés 167 majorités 84
pour 49 contre 118 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté à main levée l'amendement
numéro 24 double avis des favorables qui
épourt qui est contre il est rejeté le
17 même ma vie même vote
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre voilà
maintenant numéro 18 double avis
défavorable je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 169 exprimés 167 majorités 84
pour 50 contre 117 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté à main levée l'amendement
numéro 18 double avis défavorable qui
est pour qui est contre rejeter le 28 ma
vie même vote
amendement pouvant être soumis une
discussion comme une amendement numéro
39 monsieur martinet
est-ce que vous voulez bien le défendre
avec le 40
allez
allez-y
c'est un amendement de notre
c'est un amendement de notre excellent
collègue William Martinez qui demande à
geler les loyers car comme vous le savez
la crise du logement ça grave
profondément et fait exploser la
précarité dans tout le pays par ailleurs
la propriété des logements contrairement
à ce qui est dit sur ces banques la
propriété des logements en location et
de plus en plus concentrée dans notre
pays environ 50% des logements sont la
propriété de 3,5% des ménages les
impayés de loyer augmentent de façon
inquiétante c'est plus 10% 2022
certainement plus en 2023 le taux
d'effort ça a été dit tout à l'heure à
augmenter largement entre 2001 et 2017
il est de 28% en comptant les charges à
l'heure actuelle il est donc urgent
d'agir et votre nouvelle augmentation de
3,5% des loyers qui consécutives à
l'augmentation des 3,5% déjà permise
l'année dernière évidemment n'est pas là
pour arranger les choses faut-il
rappeler que pour le loyer moyen 600
euros par mois cela représente une
nouvelle hausse de près de 240 euros par
an depuis la création de l'IRL la valeur
la plus arme portante de son
augmentation constatée s'élever après de
2, 95%, cette augmentation de 3,5%
autorisé et donc historiquement la plus
forte dans notre pays elle est inaccepte
inacceptable et c'est pour cette raison
que nous proposons de geler les loyers
merci Monsieur gaillard la maman numéro
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mais j'ai
un collègue finalement en première
lecture comme en deuxième lecture vous
nous faites croire que vous n'avez pas
le choix soit encadrer la hausse des
loyers à 3,5% de plus par rapport à
l'augmentation de l'an dernier soit les
locataires subiraient les hausses de
plus de 6%. quel mensonge quel
malhonnêteté intellectuelle qu'elle
cynisme quel mépris vous pouvez
vous auriez pu
vous pouvez en votant l’amendement qui
vient d'être présenté par mon collègue
je l'ai les loyers en faisant voter un
IRL à 0% vous pouvez le faire à défaut
je présente un amendement de repli
puisque vous nous faites le chantage au
Conseil constitutionnel si vous
n'assumez pas de voter un IRL à zéro au
moins votez un IRL à 1% 1% moi
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qui se passe
dans vos circonscriptions mais je suis
persuadé qui se passe la même chose que
dans la mienne qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
les habitants de ma circonscription qui
sont locataires qu'ils n'en peuvent plus
parce qu'ils ont leur charge qui
explosent parce qu'ils ont les
augmentations de loyer parce que tout
augmente dans les magasins tout augmente
sauf les salaires parce que vous refusez
d'augmenter les salaires il y a eu des
mobilisations dans ma circonscription
parce que pour des locataires y compris
les locataires en logements sociaux
c'est entre 50 à 200 euros de plus par
mois entre la hausse décharge et la
hausse des loyers alors entendez
entendez au moins les cris de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre qui vous disent
qu'on est déjà dans une situation
d'explosion des impayés de loyer plus
10% en 2022 et en 2023 on sait que ça va
augmenter les chiffres je vous les
redonne le 10 du mois beaucoup non plus
que 100 euros de reste à vivre on est
dans une situation où la part des loyers
pour les 10% les plus modestes et de 42%
de leurs dépenses alors venez au moins
un gel de loyer ou un défaut une
augmentation de un point sur Madame la
Députée l'amendement numéro 27 monsieur
peut
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente en fait
c'est un bon c'est un amendement de
repli qui propose non pas un gel mais
une augmentation limitée à 1%, je
reviens pas sur les arguments pour
lesquels nous on considère qu'il faut un
effort de protection des plus des plus
modestes avec une mesure de ce type qui
je le rappelle est proposé par la
Fondation Abbé Pierre par UFC Que
Choisir par la selle CV enfin par toute
une série d'associations de défense des
consommateurs donc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement partagé je voudrais quand
même revenir juste un mot sur les
charges et sur l'APL ce qui vous aura
pas échappé que dans cette proposition
de loi telle qu'elle vient et non pas
comme un projet de loi avec toutes les
études qui auraient pu être accompagnés
l'étude de ce de cette proposition nous
ne pouvons pas
les mesures qui sont proposées ne sont
pas assorties d'une revalorisation des
aPL ce qui risque justement de ne pas
permettre aux appels de couvrir la part
d'augmentation des loyers et je rappelle
que le décret charge qui calcule ce que
l'APL ce que les appelle couvrent en
plus du loyer la part des charges
qu'elle couvre dans les aides c'est
environ 40% des charges qui sont prises
en compte dans le calcul de l'appel pour
ceux qui en bénéficient et vous savez
très bien qu'aujourd'hui avec
l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie
notamment les charges augmentent
considérablement sa grève le pouvoir
d'achat des foyers modestes et que l'APL
elle ne les couvre pas et ne vient pas
corriger cette augmentation de la
quittance la raison pour laquelle nous
insistons sur une mesure de protection à
minima qui est celle d'augmenter dans un
une limite de 1% les loyers cette année
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la Présidente défavorable
je veux rappeler quand même sur les
charges les effets extrêmement
importants des différents boucliers que
nous avons mis en place bouclier temps
d'un point de vue individuel sur le gaz
et l'électricité et bouclier sur les
charges collectives notamment sur sur
les parties communes donc
ne dites pas que nous n'avons rien fait
au contraire personne n'a fait autant
que nous pour protéger les locataires
sur les charges et l'augmentation des
charges donc défavorables
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame et
vous aviez demandé la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente j'avoue
madame Simonet que quand vous évoquez le
cynisme s'agissant du logement social
venant de votre part c'est quand même
fort de café je trouve
maintenant madame madame shikirou
demandez la parole je suis persuadée que
Madame Fiat vous la donnera donc
laissez-moi finir mon propos je voudrais
revenir madame la Présidente si bien
évidemment cette assemblée me le permet
et si Madame chikiru veut bien garder
son calme ce qui me semble très
compliqué depuis plusieurs jours et
plusieurs semaines et bien je voudrais
juste répondre son propre de Monsieur
Martinet des propos liminaires sur
l'article 2 où il évoque des habitants
de sa circonscription qui viennent le
voir sur l'augmentation des loyers je
vais vous dire une chose Monsieur le
Député je plains les habitants qui
habitent de votre circonscription parce
que quand ils viennent vous voir et qui
partent des difficultés de loyer vous
évoquez quoi exactement vous n'évoquez
pas vous n'évoquez pas le plafonnement
des loyers
vous n'évoquez pas le plafonnement des
loyers
seul madame est à la parole
seul madame
seul madame et à la parole
[Applaudissements]
madame madame la Présidente il est vrai
qu'il y a certaines vérités qui sont
difficiles à entendre de la part des
bancs de l'extrême gauche je peux le
comprendre
maintenant si je peux revenir à mon
propos et si la France insoumise va me
laisser juste terminer Monsieur Martinet
évoque une augmentation des loyers ce
qui est prévu par l'article 2 n'est pas
une augmentation des loyers c'est un
plafonnement des loyers si cette
disposition n'était pas votée c'est 6%
d'augmentation coron vos locataires et
pas 3,5% d'augmentation des loyers
s'agissant aussi des difficultés qu'il
rencontre je vous rappelle juste que
lors de la loi de finance passée nous
avons voté le chèque énergie et quand je
dis nous avons voté je parle de cette
marjorité parce que vous n'avez pas
voulu le voter c'est 30% de non recours
du chèque énergie c'est 30% des
habitants de vos circonscriptions qui
n'ont pas eu le droit au chèque énergie
maintenant on ne se demande absolument
plus pourquoi ce que vous avancez c'est
votre idéologie votre dogme et nous le
constatons aujourd'hui c'est au
détriment des classes les plus
populaires et les plus pauvres bravo les
députés de la France insoumise vous
représentez vraiment vos habitants de la
circonscription
merci madame la députée alors je
rappelle dans cette hémicycle que
c'est un conseil que je donne et
généralement il fonctionne très bien que
si on veut parler dans le calme il est
toujours il est toujours mieux de il est
toujours mieux
je il est toujours mieux de parler à la
présidente au rapporteur au président de
la commission ou au ministre les
interpellations font que forcément les
voix s'élèvent je suspends la séance
pour 5 minutes
monsieur Martinet pour un rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur la base
de l'article 70 elle est née à 3 de
notre règlement pour mise en cause
personnelle je serai très calme très
bref très concis madame et a fait une
mise en cause personnelle puisque elle a
dit qu'elle plaignait les habitants de
ma circonscription je tiens juste à dire
que madame est très mal placé pour le
dire puisque madame a été en 2017 député
dans ma circonscription mais que en 2022
plutôt que se présenter contre moi et
prendre le risque de perdre elle a
préféré se faire recaser dans une
circonscription bourgeoise des Yvelines
pour être sûr de gagner alors
excusez-moi en termes de respect des
électeurs madame et vous n'avez pas de
leçon à donner
merci
[Musique]
merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur
le député alors
monsieur Lucas je vais vous deux je vais
vous donner la parole pour un rappel le
règlement je vous invite juste quand
vous faites les rappels de règlement si
vous pouviez éviter les rappels
règlements ou après ça va être oui d'un
rappel le règlement pour mise en cause
personnelle
monsieur Lucas pour un rappel au
Règlement sur quel fondement
[Musique]
j'ai hâte de voir une élection en posant
monsieur martinet à Madame et dans on
apprécié avec lui le résultat en
revanche madame la Présidente je note
qu'il est d'usage dans cette émission de
ne pas s'interpeller directement et je
regrette que la majorité qui passe sa
vie à nous donner des leçons de maintien
à expliquer ce qu'est un bon ou un
mauvais parlementaire à parler des
extraits à tout bout de champ se
comportent de la sorte et qu'il n'y ait
personne dans le groupe majoritaire pour
dire à Madame et qu'on interpelle pas
ses collègues de la sorte et que c'est
un débat qui concerne la vie des
Français qui concerne leur loyer qui
concerne l'horlogements qui fait appel à
des souffrances terribles dans la vie de
nos compatriotes et qu'il met
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le député
[Applaudissements]
alors vous aurez tous noté que mon rôle
de présidente avait fait en sorte que
j'avais précisé à la suite de la prise
de parole de madame la députée que
j'avais précisé que les interpellations
étaient
déconseillé dans cette hémicycle et
qu'il était bienvenu de s'adresser à la
présidente au rapporteur au président et
au ministre donc le travail j'ai envie
de dire a été fait par votre présidente
et donc votre appel au règlement et donc
satisfait chers collègues j'avais madame
la Présidente chatelas qui était
inscrite et nous passerons au vote
merci madame la Présidente
malheureusement nous avons assisté juste
avant la suspension de séance à une
stratégie bien connue qui consiste à
quand on n'a pas d'argument sur le fond
pour défendre son projet de loi ou sa
politique et ben on essaye de créer un
excellent c'est bien connu finalement ça
vous permet de couvrir vos propos et
finalement vos manques de proposition et
de logement en essayant de vous attaquer
à la forme mais cela ne fonctionne pas
regardons la politique du logement
pourquoi on parlait de cynisme sur la
politique du logement en matière de
logement social parce qu'après avoir
pris un 5 euros d'APL ou au locataire et
bien ensuite vous avez continué à
réduire les appels et il vous l'avez
fait payer par les bailleurs sociaux
c'est 1,3 milliards d'euros qui sont
pris chaque année au bailleur socio
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont du mal à
construire c'est pour ça qu'ils ont du
mal à rénover parce que vous leur prenez
leur argent et l'argent est d'ailleurs
sociaux c'est l'argent des locataires du
logement social donc c'est l'argent des
locataires que vous prenez la deuxième
chose vous voudriez qu'on se ici de plus
3,5% nous l'avons dit les salaires
n'augmentent pas d'autant ça veut dire
que le poids du logement dans le budget
des ménages va continuer à augmenter et
la deuxième chose c'est que finalement
on est on est tout à la fin de la chaîne
aujourd'hui cette politique du logement
c'est aucune politique contre la
spéculation foncière il y a 0 vision sur
le foncier c'est une politique qui me
permet pas de construire il y a une
chute de la production aussi dans ce
pays c'est une politique qui n'encadre
pas les loyers donc aujourd'hui
effectivement on en est réduit à devoir
regarder quel bouclier on peut faire le
seul bouclier qui aujourd'hui protège
véritablement les locataires contre la
hausse de logement c'est le gel vous
l'avez refusé alors on vous demande à
minima un minima de n'augmenter que de
1% les loyers c'est seulement comme ça
qu'on pourra donner un tout petit peu
d'air un tout petit peu d'air à des
millions de locataires
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues vous êtes plusieurs à vouloir
prendre la parole j'ai pris un pour un
compte vous êtes beaucoup à vouloir
voter aussi avant 20h à un moment donné
il faut faire des choix nous passons au
vote
je mets au voile l'amendement ça m'a
levée chers collègues l'amendement 39
double avis défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre rejeté amendement 40 même
avis même vote 27 même ma vie même vote
amendement numéro 6 amendement
identique
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement là aussi de repli et je
reprends les arguments de mes collègues
que ce soit sur les bancs de la France
insoumise du groupe de GDR des
socialistes pour justifier cette
amendement mais je tiens à rappeler
quand même que les impayés de loyer
augmentent de façon inquiétante dans le
pays et encore plus dans les outre-mer
le taux des forces c'est-à-dire la part
de revenus consacrés au logement ne
cesse d'augmenter ça a été dit encore
tout à l'heure et d'après l'Observatoire
des inégalités les 10 poissons les plus
modestes consacrent en 2017
42% de leurs revenus au logement et si
je prends l'exemple de Smic avec 42% de
son revenu qui passe dans le logement et
bien je vous laisse deviner ce qui se
passe dans le foyer le dispositif
de plafonnement que vous proposez
permettra une nouvelle augmentation de
3,5% des loyers vous autorisez à l'oeil
augmentation historique un record de
d'augmentation de loyer à travers votre
texte elle est inacceptable à plus forte
raison dans le contexte d'aravation de
la crise du logement que nous
connaissons il est donc
urgent de réduire le poids du logement
dans les dépenses des ménages c'est
pourquoi nous proposons un minima de
geler les loyers dans les zones tendues
merci monsieur le député l'amendement
numéro 30
monsieur peut l'amendement numéro 30
défendu
amendement numéro 7
défendu monsieur le rapporteurs
[Musique]
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur très
rapidement moi je simplement on suit on
fait une suspension de séance je me
demande en ces amendements côté nupest
si finalement vous regrettez pas de pas
avoir posé vous-même cette proposition
de loi je trouve que c'est une occasion
manquée de pas voter ce texte à
l'unanimité qui est un texte équilibré
qui permet de contenir la hausse des
loyers à 3 et demi pour cent on pense
aux 40000 petits commerçants et artisans
qui l'attendent aux particuliers c'est
un texte qui a une sécurité juridique le
Sénat en revanche côté républicain on ne
sait plus trop où s'y retrouver parce
que franchement là d'avoir laissé filer
filer la hausse des loyers donc là voilà
un texte de compromis donc je vous
propose de le voter tous ensemble merci
merci monsieur le député
je mets au voile les amandes
l'amendements
ils sont rejetés je me vois l'amendement
numéro 7 même ma vie même vote
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je mets au voile article 2 je
vous prie de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 173 exprimés 173 majorités 97
pour 125 contre 48 l'absente des
nationales à adopté
nous passons au titre amendement numéro
8 monsieur Martinez
merci madame la Présidente bon d'abord
je ne résiste pas à rebondir sur
l'intervention du collègue de la
minorité présidentielle excusez-moi
c'est l'hôpital qui se moque de la
charité quand quand vous nous dites vous
vous auriez voulu présenter une
proposition de loi pour encadrer les
loyers mais chers collègues tous les
groupes de la nups ici présents ont
déposé ces derniers mois des
propositions de loi pour encadrer geler
les loyers en 2023 et en 2024 l'un
préparation elle est de votre côté et en
particulier du côté du gouvernement qui
n'a pas anticipé la fin de la mesure que
nous avons votée l'année dernière et ce
qui explique le dépôt dernier moment
d'une proposition de loi et toutes les
difficultés qu'on avait donc
l'amateurisme excusez moi il est de
votre côté ensuite sur le titre de cette
proposition de loi enfin sur
l'amendement nous proposons tout
simplement un peu de clarté politique de
changer le titre pour dire que cette
proposition de loi vise à augmenter
drastiquement les loyers en fait d'une
certaine façon le son il s'agit
d'empêcher la minorité présidentielle de
se cacher derrière son petit doigt de se
cacher derrière son petit doigt quand
vous dites si nous n'avons rien fait
avec l'inflation les loyers auront
augmenté plus oui ok nous le savons
chers collègues mais nous savons que le
choc inflationniste en caduque le mode
de calcul de l'IRL et que donc il
revient à la responsabilité de la
représentation nationale de voter et de
décider du niveau de l'IRL donc est-ce
que c'est 0 % est-ce que c'est 3,5 ou
est-ce que c'est 6 %, c'est un choix
politique chacun ici a ses choix
politiques et effectivement nous n'avons
pas les mêmes mais il faut les assumer
et puis pour finir toujours sur la
clarté politique chers collègues arrêtez
de vous cacher derrière Laurent Fabius
franchement il y en a marre la carte
Laurent Fabius elle vous a déjà bien
servi pendant la réforme des retraites
pour faire passer toutes les mesures et
les organisations antidémocratiques que
vous avez imposées là s'il vous plaît ne
nous faites pas le coup avec cette
proposition de loi si vous voulez que
les loyers augment ent ne vous cachez
pas derrière une éventuelle décision du
Conseil constitutionnel mais assumer vos
décisions
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
non c'est pas un amendement de clarté
c'est un amendement mensongé depuis le
début vous essayez et de provocation
depuis le début vous essayez de
renverser le débat nous protégeons les
locataires comme nous avons protégé les
commerçants les PME et les TPE et mon
collègue mourenet a raison je pense que
vous auriez aimé la défendre et la
proposer
monsieur le ministre
cette proposition de loi est
équilibrée elle permet de continuer à
protéger les locataires d'une
augmentation de loyer qui serait
extrêmement importante et donc cet avis
est défavorable merci
amendement avec Wavre
able qui est contre
l'amendement est rejeté n'ayant que de
n'ayant que deux demandes une seule
0 je n'ai pas de demande d'explication
de
attendez attendez
j'ai une demande d'explication de vote
je vous propose de prendre cette demande
d'explication de votre pour que nous
puissions passer au vote avant que je
lève la séance si vous en êtes d'accord
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur est-ce
que Damien sera invité comme Monsieur
kasbariian chez Monsieur Hanouna sur
TPMP Damien il raconte son histoire dans
Sud-Ouest le 2 juin dernier Monsieur
cavardian calmez-vous ici c'est fini
pour moi mais je veux témoigner de ce
que j'ai vécu pour pour que les gens
prennent conscience tu sors fait au
jeûne car je ne suis pas le seul dans
cette situation
quatre de mes copains sont dans le même
cas quand le président Macron dit qu'il
suffit de traverser la rue pour trouver
un boulot il oublie qu'il faut aussi un
logement Damien souvient de son arrivée
à Bayonne en juillet 2022 pour un job
chez McDo il vit alors chez une amie qui
le dépanne le temps pour lui de trouver
un chez soi il découvre alors les
difficultés locales il avoue à regret je
n'étais pas au courant que c'était si
galère la chance lui sourit en septembre
il obtient un CDI dans un Intermarché
seulement les biens sont rares et les
loyers trop chers pour son budget du T1
600 euros au T2 à 700 à quoi s'ajoutent
les charges son dossier ne passe pas en
décembre tout se précipite il est
contraint de quitter son hébergement et
il explique j'ai dormi pendant trois
jours dans des toilettes publiques je
finissais mes nuits à l'Intermarché en
m'irandant à l'ouverture à 4h du matin
décembre le froid la rue le gamin
volontaire s'accroche à son boulot
j'adore ce que je fais mes collègues les
clients c'est tout pour moi de guerlas
Damien Dieu abandonné rien d'assez
probant ne s'est invité pour trouver un
logement il a dû quitter son travail
vous en fichez peut-être mais c'est la
vie de millions de personnes
est-ce que Anne-Sophie sera invité chez
TPMP Anne-Sophie qui dit dans le
Télégramme le 5 juin si on avait eu un
logement il n'aurait jamais fait ça en
parlant de son conjoint Pascal qui s'est
suicidé parce qu'il vivait dans une
tente depuis deux mois alors qu'il
gagnait 2000 euros par mois mais ne
trouvez pas de logement pourquoi parce
que les loyers augmentent parce qu'on
demande au locataire parfois trois fois
leur loyer en guise de caution voilà la
réalité de 14 millions de personnes
fragilisées par rapport au logement
il n'y aura pas de prime time non pour
Damien il n'y en aura pas pour
Anne-Sophie il n'y en aura pas pour
Pascal il n'y aura pas de prime time
mais ici il y a une loi une loi injuste
qui va mettre des gens dehors qui
s'ajoute à celle en tilocataire et qui
va augmenter les loyers des locataires
et des petites entreprises alors quoi
d'étonnant venant du gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait déjà
supprimé les APL supprimer les aides à
la pierre pour le logement social
fait des annonces décevantes en cascade
et maintenant qui augmente les loyers
quoi d'étonnant mais le fait majeur de
cette première année c'est ceux qui
disent quand je parle de Damien qu'il
s'en foutent c'est vous le rassemblement
national le fait majeur vous qui en
anneau avait été une arnaque pour les
électeurs qui ont pu penser que vous
alliez défendre les petites gens votre
contrôle augmentation du Smic et
l'indexation des salaires sur la
pression s'il vous plaît contre le gel
des loyers vote contre le rétablissement
de l'ISF abstention sur le revenu
d'autonomie pour les étudiantes et
étudiants à 1060 euros vote contre
l'indemnisation des agriculteurs
victimes de catastrophes naturelles vote
contre la régulation de l'installation
des médecins pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux et aujourd'hui vote
contre le gel des loyers un ande mandat
un Andernach pour vos électeurs qui
auraient pu penser que vous aviez
peut-être défendre les petits vous
n'aimez pas les éoliennes pourtant vous
auriez pu en faire tourner beaucoup vu
le Vogue vous avez brassé pour vous
opposer à la réforme des retraites et
aux politica juste de ce gouvernement
que vous soutenez vous aurez été plus
actif à défendre Bolloré Bernard Arnault
que les Damiens les ânes Sophie les
pascals de ce pays qui se lèvent tôt
peut-être que le parti le tennis préfère
comme ce soir défendre les multiples
propriétaires de Saint-Cloud et les
châtelains de mon retour plutôt que les
petites gens locataires ou petits
entrepreneurs qui vont voir leur loyer
augmenter pour nous la nups nous sommes
cohérents et responsables nous vous
avons proposé la garantie universelle
des loyers revaloriser les appels
réinjecter de l'argent dans le logement
social et le gel des loyers car oui
c'est une mesure de justice sociale ce
soir et nous serons toujours aux côtés
de celles et ceux qui subissent vos
politiques ajustes d'augmentation des
loyers
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre au volant de
la proposition de gloire je vous prie de
bien vouloir regagner vos places le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 195 exprimés 195 majorité 98 pour
143 contre 52 l'Assemblée nationale à
adopté prochaine séance ce soir à 21h30
suite du projet de loi adopté par le
Sénat visant à donner à la douane les
moyens de faire face aux nouvelles
menaces la séance est levée